$-Casting the Joe Rogan experience pot.
Oh,
recording.
Recording,
Here we go.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and I enter
in the code name Rogan,
you get 15% off and you can just fuck it all day long on a discount.
All right.
Cliffy bees here play that stupid music that we need to start without the music.
Yeah.
We don't even know why.
[inaudible]
whatever reason we need to do that.
That makes it seem like it's really starting.
Yeah.
It doesn't seem to me like it's starting until we do that.
The real cliffy be from,
uh,
from Twitter.
It's,
uh,
cliffy be from epic games this year,
past 90,000,
90,000 Twitter followers.
You fucking digital Ninja tip,
dude.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
My dog has 4,000.
You have a dog with 4,000 Twitter followers,
tweets about bitches and poop.
Damn.
I dog follows his dog.
Yeah.
They sniff each other's butts.
You have a dog Twitter account as well?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
It's a goddamn Twitter off right here.
Cliffy beef from a x box or from epic Games is here.
If they're doing a e three is there in la this week and all the crazy video game
shit.
I'm exhausted already.
You must be mad,
dude.
It's playing the ice tea.
You have to watching the video.
Okay.
So the thing about him is a,
apparently somebody ea was slagging me in their press conference.
They're like,
we don't bring out random celebrities into to do our press conference.
And then five seconds later Coby comes out.
You're like,
wait,
what?
And uh,
the thing about ice is I grew up listening to all his shit,
right?
Like,
uh Oh gee.
All of that.
All of his stuff,
man.
Like huge fan.
I know.
Yeah,
right.
I pulled the trigger long.
Great.
[inaudible] right.
He's great.
It's funny as Shit,
man.
He's so cool.
And so he,
he plays video games all the time.
He's good.
He knows his stuff.
He's in the game as a character and he's great because he's like Marcus Phoenix.
You know what the first rule of business,
isn't it?
The Phoenix me mother fucker.
Right.
Writing.
Great.
Right.
And uh,
and he's just cool.
So he came out and I got to demo.
He's one of my heroes.
Right.
But you got damn good iced tea impression about it.
Dude.
I've been listening to him forever,
man.
Like Freddie Lockhart,
you'd have an ice tea off.
She'd should be like a national competition.
Like,
like,
like a Chili Cook off.
Right.
It's a complicated impression.
You got a little lisp to it.
Yeah.
A little thumping going on and yet you have a little list and still have to
sound like you could jump up and kick your acid anymore.
Right.
This is the attitude behind it all was going on.
She got the ass on cogo she got an ass side of Alaska.
Right.
Who?
She's a fucking sweetheart too,
by the way.
Is She?
She is like the coolest chick man.
And uh,
yeah,
they got the shovel and the blowing up right now.
So good for him,
man.
Yeah.
Good for him.
And he always seemed to be an interesting character.
So I read book,
I hadn't read his biopic of course before,
you know,
cause I had,
I had followed him and I knew most of its history and everything.
And,
uh,
we're sitting there backstage and you get them going on these stories,
but he's talking about the smash and grabs they used to do.
They had these little baby sledgehammers and they'd go into the jewelry stores
and they'd be,
they look at each other and be like,
if the coast was clear,
he looked at his buddy,
be like,
is it a bet buddy?
Go,
it's a bat.
And they take the sledgehammers and they'd smash the glass cases and just grab
as many Rolexes as they can and book it out of the mall.
Right.
And they had it down to a science.
But I mean,
I'm sitting there and after I read the book,
I'm like,
dude,
like,
did you work gloves?
Like class?
This is fucking class we're talking about.
Right.
And he walks up to me and he shows me his hands and there's just fucking scars
all over his fingers,
man.
Oh Man.
So he did it that often.
Yeah.
He tries that endearing checkered pasts,
man.
Why is that endearing?
Because he practiced what he preached,
man.
Then he got up the digest.
Is that it?
He was honest about it.
Oh,
he's got this story in the book.
He says there's one time where he was going to take steal this part off of a
portion of parking lot.
Right.
And he just started blowing up with all the rap and everything and all of a
sudden he's about to like,
you know,
take the car cover off this portion kind of jacked apart.
I'll send,
here's all the screaming behind them and it's all these kids who are just coming
at him just like,
and he's sitting there like,
alright,
I gotta quit.
Stay on the shit.
Like that was his quote.
What happened to the sound?
Yeah,
I lost my audio man.
We all lost audio for a second.
I turn it up right up there,
right?
Yeah.
But it just stopped.
What happened?
It's this thick socks.
So the kicker is,
sorry,
he's bringing body count back together for performance to know,
oh my God,
are they going to go cop killer?
I can't confirm or deny.
He's a cop now.
You can't sync cop killer when you've been working as a cop cop actor now,
how long has he been doing cheers,
dude.
He's going to be getting those little green envelopes on a regular basis now.
Is it the ice t became a cop on a TV show right after that cop killer
controversy.
I'm a motherfucking cop killer thing about that song.
Those he opens it up and he see,
he said specifically for any copies ever abused his authority or inappropriately
beat somebody down.
That's what he wanted to go for him.
That's a nice little disclaimer.
Every cop I've,
this is going to sound like a fucking stretch,
so bear with me,
but I've always identified with gangster rap in a certain way.
Look,
stick with this.
Okay.
Not because I'm a fucking white kid from the burbs.
Right.
And the,
and introduced a whole new world to me,
but it was the persecution from the government that I've always identified with
because it's like I can't listen to that rap music complaining that violent
video games and it's what's responsible for society's problems.
It's like,
no,
that's not the problem,
dude.
You're just trying to look for an easy solution,
right?
Yeah.
It's a mirror of society.
It's,
you mean it let a lot of people in on a,
a part of the world that they have?
No,
no other really like voice from,
where were you during the La Riots?
I was in,
I was in New York.
I hadn't moved here yet.
That was after the Rodney King you mean?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
I hadn't moved here yet.
In laverne working at Mcdonald's.
I remember watching it on TV going,
this is the end of the war.
Reginald Denny getting,
remember that helicopter when the guy fucking threw a brick at his head,
dude's smashed him full clip with a brick in his head.
Random innocent truck driver.
Do you remember?
We had to see him on TV,
meet with the guy.
Was It on Oprah?
One of those shots.
I remember one of those shows that guy actually met with them and Reginald
Denny's heads are all fucked up.
The guy threw the brick man.
Yes,
yes.
Awkward.
Ooh,
fuck.
So yeah,
he's gonna.
We're digging to that party tonight and it's going to be awesome.
I don't think there's going to be much mushing though.
It's usually it's going to,
these parties are fucking hilarious dude.
Cause what you get,
it's like jaded game journalists and celebrities and they're all kind of like,
ah,
what's up?
How's it going?
And I heard that a halo had their last party and the Bieber showed up.
Right.
And apparently this is secondhand,
but apparently some of the bungee guys really pissed like what the fuck's he
doing here?
And I'm like,
dude,
don't be so short shortsighted phenomenon right now.
You should be on to have him playing your game and hadn't seen
the kid.
He's talented dude.
I know,
but he's like 16 or something.
Right.
Have you seen,
how could she be fucking mad as a 16 year old kid singing 16 year old kid songs?
The caterer is a global phenomenon and what the fuck man,
people,
people will get angry though.
Fucking faggot.
Don't want to fucking kill that kid.
That's new England mentality.
That was,
that was me growing up in Boston and was like what's with that guy?
Where did all the girls like and what could kick his fucking earth kids?
A queer.
He looks wicked queer and it turns out it was George Michael and he was,
but that wasn't,
that's besides the point,
right?
Boston was always a a,
that's a hard ass town.
I was there for two weeks recently doing a movie and I never spent,
I haven't spent that much time in Boston and a long time.
It's always been like a couple days.
I go in for gigs and then leave.
I was thinking even the whole see hex thing.
Did you see the fighter see acts thing?
That's my description of a lot of Boston women.
The fighter that,
yes,
those are all Christian Bale sisters,
right?
That was the dating pool growing up,
dude.
There were monsters.
The accent
to me,
like I'm some kind of
say like guys who at
Children's museum there and there was this woman and her kid was climbing up.
There's a little thing at the Museum of Science.
No,
there's a kid's museum,
the children's museum,
and there's this crazy thing.
There were the kids climb up and she goes,
you can't go in there.
You too lit.
Oh he gotta be foul.
She said,
your Dick just weathers smells like rotten ass breath.
It's just everything.
It's just,
you just imagine what kind of a monster that it,
little mustache and the hair is off.
And the scary thing about it is nothing more dangerous than a person who's dumb
and doesn't know it and thinks they're smart because it's that you'll,
these guys can't fool me.
You know,
type mentality.
It's fucking horrified.
It's a fun town though,
man.
I'm telling you.
1230 it's,
it's fun.
At 1232 you just got to look out.
Well,
you can get more care.
You can defend yourself.
It's not a,
it's not a town that you want to get in an argument with people cause it turns
into,
they turn into fist fights all the time.
My favorite part of the fight,
or though it,
those girls just like,
oh,
she's that MTV girl.
She's at MTV who I,
she got three sons.
I know that girl.
Right?
Go get her.
Let's get her right.
It's fucking unbelievable.
Yeah,
that'll be a good show for the whole thing is uh,
what was going to get some celebrity showing up apparently on mini me might be
rolling up.
Oh no way.
Cool thing.
Right?
Like last time I saw it,
it was on that reality show where he was all fucked up on the little scooter
pissing in the corner.
I met,
I met the girl that did the sex tape with him and it's really weird talking to
her because he was like climbing all over and shit like Gollum,
right?
Like yeah,
it was so weird.
You met her to remember she came whenever I need her.
I stayed back while everybody else met her and I observed,
she kind of scares me cause like she seems like she's kind of like I,
that's her job.
Like she'd find somebody and it's like,
Hey,
I'm going to make a sex tape with this person because I know people are willing.
You got to,
you gotta really be careful around a person who's willing to make a mini me sex
tape.
Right.
That's what I'm saying.
He's willing to do two steps away from Schweizer.
Yeah.
It's two steps away from you.
You know,
you're just doing something dangerous.
You had some old story about him and some porn dude who used to pick up girls or
something,
right?
Like,
Huh?
Oh No.
I know a parent dude who's to told me that his move was,
he would get his whole arm in there and work the fingers and apparently he
dilated her cervix or something like that.
It's the crane kick.
It's fucking most of the monkey.
Yeah.
Steals monkey steals the peach.
It's a,
it's too powerful.
You can't defend it.
Apparently.
I heard that like,
you just,
you just orgasm like you get shot with,
you know,
like he can leave.
He flies across the room like he shot out of a fucking cannon.
Alright.
Why don't think he does.
Yeah.
Right.
He rockets out of her Jesus.
Yeah,
that'll sound,
it's apparently it says fucking strong move.
All right.
Just a little person or,
so you know many me but
pornography.
No,
he did a,
he does that with consenting adults by close doors.
It's a fascinating time,
isn't it?
With all the sex tapes.
It's like you're allowed to do that.
Lively and again,
her images that fucking uh,
those that are senator wiener and he's like,
was like,
he like tweeting porn stars photos and shit.
Like dude,
like really like porn stars.
Yeah.
There's some girl like Amy Lee or something like that,
that something like that dude there you were talking about that in one of the
podcasts,
the current state of pornography where you get that big fat dude with the food.
Fucking all these hot girls,
like what's his name?
Uh,
the fucking grim Laine guy.
And we'd have that big nasty guy that just gets hot chicks because that's
almost,
there'd porns looking for a new route and that's just one of them.
But the Internet is accelerating the cycle of depravity,
right?
Where like it used to be this like underground stuff.
You'd have to,
it'd be hard to find it now.
It's just like anything,
where's it going to be in five years?
Like I'm a completely horrified,
right?
Yeah.
No one would have ever anticipated like a whole section on cream pies.
Right.
Would be something because you were talking about gaping and all this shit and
like you sit here and like,
there's just like normal young,
beautiful 23 year old girls.
They're just like,
oh,
that's cool,
I'm doing this.
And you're like,
and that was one of other,
the thing about dating in La,
I just talking to a buddy who lived out here for awhile and he wound up,
uh,
he's dating a girl for a little while.
I want to be in that Chloe porn girl.
I remember her fucking name.
Like,
like totally nasty green haven.
He was two weeks.
It was chasing Amy moment.
Right.
And then you found out who the fuck she was and she didn't even say anything.
I think you're right though about the internet accelerating the,
a deranged pornography fortune.
I don't think gaping was going on,
you know,
a hundred years ago before the Internet,
before any kind of television,
any kind of,
especially with Twitter and everything too.
We are so able to be connected to people immediately.
Right.
As far as like,
I know about celebrity deaths now because of Twitter.
Like a day before CNN picks up on that Shit,
right?
Like Sean Kingston crashed is a jet ski and a fucking bridge.
Like I knew that like,
because it was a trending topic and I was like,
okay,
I know you know,
day later CNN alert.
Right?
So that's the fucking world we live in and we'd have to be connected 24,
seven to right.
You have to add it.
I'm sitting there like a she Lawrence playing assassin's creed and I'm on my
phone checking my Twitter,
I'm on,
I'm on my iPad checking my Facebook.
It's just like,
and we need that feed.
Our brains are being retrained for this kind of world and that's actually the
kind of games we have to make now that kind of tap into that stuff I would think
of me.
What do you think about the iPad?
Cause it seems like the IPAD and the iPhone has come out of nowhere.
You,
you have a great game on there,
uh,
over at epic and you ought to not,
some of it's come out of nowhere.
What are you talking about?
Well,
I mean it,
that the game boy was last year's huge thing.
Everyone had game boys game boy,
Nintendo was making shitloads of money and now out of nowhere a phone system.
So the three Ds was the shit.
I bought it.
I love it.
Right.
That augmented reality stuff's great.
Have you seen that?
Yes.
Right.
It's so,
it's got a 3-d screen,
but it also has a camera.
So we can use this augmented reality shit where you can take a little card and
you put it down and then you move the three Ds and view it and out of the car to
fucking dragon will pop like in your room and then it will bend.
You're like surface of your,
your,
uh,
you know,
shower or floor or whatever.
Like,
and it's just,
it's like crazy shit.
Wow.
I sat there,
I put Lauren on the bed and I put the fucking card in her stomach and this
dragon came out like fucking aliens.
Like it was a chest burster I was fucking crazy.
And it looks really good.
It looks great.
Yeah.
But the,
you know,
unintended cause they're announcing all sorts of stuff about that right now the
press conference.
Incredible.
See that's not something I ever would have thought of.
The future of technology is sometimes the emerging of several things.
That's why you know people are like why do you look conduct?
I'm like cause it's not just the camera,
it's the motion control stuff.
And if the audio as far as votes,
voice recognition,
that's what makes it fucking cool.
Right.
Okay.
Love it.
I love the net.
Just a look like Netflix.
It's going like hey I have no page two.
So minority report type things.
I want this movie.
Yeah that's your order.
You can also people that are listening on Itunes,
he's just waving his hands back and forth.
So that's all you have to do to change.
Yeah.
I got it in the other room we could do a dance off.
I've got some dance evacuated that are you a dance off master?
I fucking pants off.
Dance off all that often.
So I stripper pants and I just tear that shit off.
Do you have velcro on the side?
Like a basketball player.
We so mad though about that game.
I love that fucking game.
But you know the part where the breakdown where in the middle of the game you
just do whatever you want.
There has to be a way to save that.
So much fun shit going on.
Time it did it.
So what happens to break it down?
It's a dance Gamey dads and then it has freestyle mode and you just move and
it's like you don't really know what's going on,
but what you don't know is it's recording you with a video camera.
Right?
The first time I did it I'm pulling down my pants and like shaking my shit
around and everything like that.
And then what it does is it plays it back Benny Hill style.
So like twice as fast.
And so there's you just like shaking your shit.
And I was like,
Oh fuck.
I hope it didn't record this man.
But some of the beauty of this is connected,
connected,
sexy,
right?
So,
and I dug the,
the police station moved because the place,
she moves like a week controller,
but you have these two glowing orbs and you're like,
look like you're bringing a plane in and it's,
it's,
it is what it is.
But imagine like those kinds of controls,
but you doing any fucking trailer,
the camera can detect you and they just announced they can detect the finger
movement.
It's that and it does instant face recognition.
So she's playing dance central.
I walk by,
it's like cliff's signed in.
I'm like,
fuck man,
it's little.
It's a big brother in your living room,
right?
You see transcendent man?
No,
it's the Ray Kurzweil documentary and one of the guys in the documentary is uh,
a pioneer on a human computer interfaces.
He hasn't been planted in his body.
And then he has it set up so that he walks into a room,
they go,
good morning Bob.
Like it recognizes him.
Like when you're going through a guarded guard,
gated community,
you have one of those things in your window and the scanner recognizing it lifts
up the gates.
I'm ready for the singularity.
I blowed my computer right now.
Cynthia and computers are going to decide that were retarded because that's the
most likely scenario to me.
If I look at the way any intelligent life form that we're aware of,
whether it's chimpanzees,
human beings,
killer whales,
dolphins,
they all do evil,
fucked up shit to everything they can.
It's the matrix,
right when you're talking about,
it's been 10 years since that and if you go weaving in there,
he's like,
human beings,
your disease.
We are the cure.
Right.
That's a pretty good impression of him too.
That's still holds up by the way.
Every that shit,
fuck yeah,
that movie's so solid.
That was stitch is why it's so sad that the second one sucked so much I then
they did that.
They didn't happen.
That was fine.
The other ones like it was a third one was even worse.
It was like,
what are you doing?
Well,
this is,
this is a problem in video games have,
right,
and this is why it's really fucking hard to make a good superman game.
You have a character arc.
You want a character to do something.
At the end of your movie that he hasn't done at the beginning.
Classic screenwriting one on one.
Right?
Uh,
but if you make your guy,
God,
where do you go from there?
And so they made him superman at the end of the first movie.
So where do you go?
Right.
He's got to lose his power.
Yeah.
Exact kryptonite loses back.
Get it back with the fuck.
It's so simple.
And I never figured that out.
Well they do.
And then you superman movie with us acts Snyder,
right?
Well that dude is nuts too,
Isn't one of them.
Uh,
he's a heavy cross dresser and then he what of uh,
yeah,
it was,
I think it was Larry Rakowski decided to go transgender.
Dude,
man,
you know,
it might not be nuts.
I'll be saying in all the rest,
but when I was younger I used to be like,
what the Fuck's wrong with you?
You fucking Weirdo.
And I'm sitting there like,
can you imagine it?
Would it be like every day to wake up and think that you're in the fucking wrong
gender,
recognizing that she had a horrible,
horrible,
I've seen the operation.
If you've looked up like what they do
willingly go through that in order to get to you and we've seen it all right.
Like you know there's people man,
that they're,
they're
not happy with who they are and they will decide,
you know,
what,
whatever it needs to be to make them whole and make them whole.
And for some it's a sexual thing and for some it's a psychological thing.
But the idea behind it,
man,
you're going to chop your fucking egg financially like a hot dog,
which throw an apple core in there and clear out an opening.
There are a little nutmeg on that.
Can you imagine going through medical school,
Jesse?
You can do that to people though.
That's the one you need to look at.
Like,
all right,
you know,
it's the guy decides to become a gynecologist,
right?
Or doing it in like hotel rooms,
office buildings.
I shit ever seen paint Olympics.
They've done documentaries on guys who do like sex changes and it's like
discount sex changes.
Yeah.
That's not something you want to just count on the people who were involved,
you know,
the people that are uh,
so confused that they want to change their gender.
You know,
I'll think a lot of those people can be led in some really fucking creepy ways.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
part of it's,
uh,
I don't,
I,
you know,
one thing you have to be careful of is his charisma and when you get a person
who can be led easily,
it's the cult mentality.
Also when you have,
you know,
a god we were talking about all the other day,
I,
the whole Hale Bopp thing that happened years back where they,
you know,
that crazy fucker and all the people with those are the things that Nike's and
everything,
right?
Like that.
Like that's all it takes is one charismatic fucker fixate everyone else on one
concept,
one charismatic dude to get a huge podcast and huge following on Twitter scene.
No one is really confident as to where this life is going.
Yes.
He was completely confused.
And if someone comes along and they seem like they're confident,
our natural monkey,
yeah,
we just follow that guy.
He's confident.
I'm not,
he's speaking like he has the facts.
he says he was touched by God,
I believe in God.
And the next thing you know,
they're fucking drinking the Koolaid art sort of our archetype,
old DNA is people is to,
uh,
to search for those sorts of figures throughout history that religious icons and
you know,
people are naturally drawn.
And I think it's a byproduct of evolution looking for a leader to follow so you
can be successful in the same way because nobody knows what the fuck's going on
anywhere in the operating system that you can exploit.
You know?
I mean really that's what it is.
We really do need it,
you know?
I mean,
and the,
those though,
that's the system can be manipulated to the system can be hijacked by different,
you know,
fucked up things that can happen in your life.
Like the reason why he girls who don't have daddy's become strippers,
you know what I mean?
Like what's that from?
It's just extraordinary need for male attention because a deficits been created.
So this natural system,
it's set up in place.
It's been hijacked by a deficit,
and I used to love titty bars when I was married to June.
That's when a lot of people love them.
Right.
Chris rock says somebody's got to entertain the married men of America.
If your daughter's a stripper,
you fucked up.
That is indeed true.
I'll look.
He's hit.
His Shit's still holds up,
man.
I fucking love it.
All of it.
Yeah,
it does.
Like you go back and watch and be a bigger and blacker and never scared and
everything.
It's just
especially bigger and blacker.
That's one of the best comedy performances ever.
I've always been classic.
I've always believed that a lot of what my personal belief of good comedy is
calling out the shit that everybody knows is true.
That never realized it in a public venue.
Yeah.
And things that,
you know,
everybody knows it's true,
but you're not supposed to touch on,
you know,
like his,
the one bit that he did that he had the hardest time with was the,
I love black people.
I hate niggers and that bit it's a genius fucking bit.
Apparently Chris rock bombed with that bit for like a year.
Really couldn't get it to work with it.
Just stuck with it because the tweak was the tweak that did it.
Who knows?
You know,
it's like there's some bits that you don't know what it is.
He just,
you know,
there's a concept in there,
but you just can't find a way to get other people to see it the way you,
you,
you know,
the weights in your mind.
It's like,
and sometimes he'd just,
it just,
you got to try it a bunch of different ways.
But apparently he stuck with it for a long time and then it became unstoppable.
It's so funny,
like us.
So sitting here and hanging out backstage with ice tea and talking about,
cause he's doing this documentary called the art of rap where he like went
around and interviewed like everybody,
you got everybody from like Doug e fresh to m and M.
Right?
And he's just like talking about the rap game.
And then when I get like moments to chat with you and talk about how comedians
are the comedian circle and then realizing how that applies to like game
designer creatives and how like,
you know,
I'm texting like Ken Levine and he's like,
oh,
I hope you can come by and see the new bio shock.
I'm like,
ah,
fuck yeah,
dude,
I'm day fucking one.
Right.
And uh,
and so I've realized from my position,
you know,
and being fairly physical and games and having some success with it,
like,
you know,
we all need to like fucking stick together,
Dude.
Like,
you know,
I'm,
I'm specifically when I was in Boston,
the last,
you know,
went out with Ken and his wife and we had dinner and like comparing notes about
things like that,
especially with game developers because we're not,
you know,
rappers who are out there like,
what's up?
We're not competing to get on stage where usually the kind of guys in the back
of the room like,
you know,
ain't nothing going on,
right?
So it's like,
it is like that,
you know,
people want to assume that there's a fucking war going on at all times,
right?
Halo,
don't you hate on chartered?
I'm like,
no,
they're good and I'll play the fuck out of them.
What's your problem?
Right.
Well,
that's healthy.
Some people aren't healthy.
Some people can't have competition.
They can't have anybody out there that's doing what they're doing because they
are in battle to be number one because they're not secure with who they are.
They're not comfortable and they're fucking crazy,
which is why they got to be where they got in the first place.
The Internet does help those people very much.
Now,
the obsession the Preston kills me though,
cause that's the beauty of Twitter is you can catch that shit immediately.
And I had a story.
I'm so after e three,
um,
uh,
taking my sabbatical,
I've been working since I was fucking 17.
I'm taking a month off gears as they're ironing out a couple of final bucks.
It's pretty much done,
right?
So we're going to Mexico,
we're going to Barcelona,
I'm going to have fun.
Right?
And I tweeted it like,
you know,
I'm going to go on sabbatical for a month,
right?
A reporter who I know by the way,
who actually is a friend of mine for some reason picked this up and he's like
Blah Sinskey to retire after e three.
I'm like,
there's a big fucking difference between a sabbatical and retiring dude.
Like what are you doing?
Right?
Desperate for.
Well,
so what it is,
it's,
people only read the poll quote,
you know,
and it's,
it's just like,
and then they don't even read where people clarify it.
They jump immediately to the flame war and that's how shit happens.
Cause people are like anger,
they love fights.
They'll controversy.
Let people have beef,
right?
That whole ice tea and soldier boy thing.
And it happened a while ago.
People still asking,
okay,
well ice tea,
seriously,
ice tea,
put sunglasses on,
which you always lose if you're standing in front of a camera and you're making
your point and you're wearing sunglasses.
What the fuck are you doing?
All right,
what does this amazing,
you're on soldier boy's size [inaudible] side.
Cause I saw the boy didn't do anything wrong.
Soulja boy was making songs that some fucking 16 year old kid would make.
I mean that's what he was doing.
Would you rather hang out with those?
For sure,
but I would have rather ice tea,
smoke a joint and reassess that situation before it calls out some 16 year old
kids like picking one rap like is like,
you know,
be just compared to electroplate a beaver a little bit.
I did.
It's like a little kid,
the black Bieber and he looks like he's having fun.
Like what the fuck do you care if it's not your style,
you don't like it.
So I headaches this big stupid video about it and Soulja boy soldier,
you might hear some things that ice tea said.
So he responds.
And then ice tea,
make some video about it where he stands in front of the camera and with
sunglasses on.
And I love ice tea.
I'm an ice into that.
It was propositive somehow like in,
in the middle of this shit because what happened was like a met Soulja boy a
couple of years ago to e three,
and he's really helpful and really nice in a war.
Well,
I'm going to have to be strapped everywhere I go down,
it goes down.
If the ship goes down the ice,
the game.
And soldier tweeted me the other day,
he's like,
Yo man,
how come you don't follow me?
I thought we were friends.
Oh Shit.
So,
and this was like two days before body count reunion,
all this shit.
I'm like,
okay,
you have a fall Soulja boy.
I hope he doesn't sales ice tea shit.
Right?
So that was fucking awkward.
But speaking of sunglasses,
they need to get it together and let it go.
If there's this,
uh,
this dude speaking to connect,
have you,
do you know who killed your boy?
You know,
you know Kudo,
go to Sonata.
What?
Brian?
He's the main connect creative guy.
Right?
Okay.
Yeah.
Really cool dude.
Right?
Real chill.
Right.
And uh,
he,
he's one of the sunglass guys and wears them indoors.
He wasn't all the fucking time.
That's why the thing is,
is I asked him,
I'm like,
dude.
And he's like,
he's like a,
he has really super sensitive to like light because you go out on stage like
that while you look like a Douche.
Now this shit is ridiculous.
You look like you're in a lecture so you can have conversations with people and
just,
I'm going to cut off this sense.
I don't want you look into my eyes,
you know,
I'm just going to look at this little thing about him is the internet,
but just because of that one fucking factor just because of the sunglasses.
There's a website,
Kudos,
a douche.com and they've taken everything from him like every quote,
every image,
and they just bagged on them all the time.
Right.
And Center and I had the same shit,
like I still get shit.
I used to wear earrings or like big diamond studs and some do at one point they
just got stolen from me.
Like they just vanished my fucking house,
which is scary shit to have happened to you by the way.
And uh,
then like I was stopped wearing my start doing interviews.
Suddenly I'm reading the comments.
I'm starting to like cliff now.
I used to think he was a Douche just because of the fucking earrings.
Yeah,
you gotta be careful.
I wear a wallet chain.
I'm 43 years old.
It's very dangerous.
Very Douche.
Hot Topic.
No Man,
I hadn't made custom jewelry.
I lost my wallet once,
no twice in the early nineties.
I said,
this is ridiculous.
I go out and get fucked up too much.
I need something that connects my wallet to my body.
And so I got a boy.
I've found wall chains.
Like,
you know you can get a chain,
you're kind of wearing it like a badge though now you know like I lose my wallet
frequently so like I need to belt the shit.
No,
I like to change.
I think it's a cool,
that one's sweet.
You got a bad mother fucking officially cool again.
By the way.
Is that what you said?
Last podcast?
Did he put that out?
That's the shit out anywhere.
But why not parties but Mitzvah.
You're a smart man though.
You go wallet in the front pocket,
which is the move never in the back of your right.
That's the correct.
Funny cause like a hair won't grow there now cause I always have my phone and
shit.
Fuck that hair laser.
Right.
We're a little fucking patches.
It's so smart too because that's fucks your backup.
Having that wallet in the back,
sit on it all the time.
I always take it out when I sit down,
which is also a good thing when it's connected bikes and skulls on it as a mace.
Fuck you up.
There's an amazing,
you can't bring a a pool cue on a plane,
but I could bring this chain,
I'll kill you with this chain wrap to shut her up behind you in the airport
security dude,
you fucking pulling metal off of everyone.
He gets a big race and you,
you know a belt.
He could kill someone.
That belt pretty God damn easy.
Well,
we're actually at the point now in the airplane if you,
if you get upgraded to first class where that you can actually have metal now,
right?
Oh yeah.
The little tiny metal.
What are the lessons I learned flying those,
if you're ever in a,
in the seats that are kind of like fabric,
it's okay to let when rip,
but if you're in the leather ones that she goes to food right back on carpet
bomb the whole [inaudible] cycle so quick and you just see everybody cringing
and crumbling around you.
I was doing the,
the UFC the other day and someone wouldn't stop forwarding through the whole
production and I don't,
I didn't know if it was Goldberg or the production assistant or Joe Silva was
someone was just opening hours for hours,
too much gaping.
So I blamed one dude and I'm pretty sure I'm correct.
It was my radar.
If it looks like a duck,
smells like shit.
Go with my instincts.
Like sometimes if it's totally silent,
you have to watch their facial expressions and the subtle nuance.
It was brutal.
I would caught trying to concentrate on the fights that I was going.
You Stinky mother fucker.
It was like a percentage of my brain.
It was going,
I can't believe you're doing this to me.
I see what were saying.
Dana white pop id,
Xbox event.
And he just fucking come right in and goes right out.
And it's funny cause there's people who know Dana and how huge all the shit is.
And there's those who don't like with the folks with the guys.
Like dude,
he's leading his own religion at this point.
Right.
And,
uh,
one of my favorite hobbies right now is watching Jenna and Tito fight on
Twitter.
Like what the fuck dude?
Like,
oh my God,
if my style,
a thief gay wasn't even like that tea.
There's like,
you're a whore.
I use like what the fuck was unbelievable.
Like
they need some friends.
What Ha happened?
This thing?
Yeah,
man.
I just turn it up right there.
It's,
oh Jesus.
Brian,
just turn it up right here.
Yeah.
Your volume control.
How did it die off?
Because it was just turned up.
Nevermind.
Technical Talk.
Oh,
that's super technical.
Camera's technical as you get,
Hey,
get any more dogs from many ex girlfriends.
Yeah,
there's actually a second one back there now.
There's two dogs now is the current one,
right?
Uh,
yeah.
And I'm about to get another pet.
I think I'm just going to get snakes,
snake,
all the other
rather than a car,
you're going to get a huge lizard or ups,
I guess he come home.
There's body parts.
I want to get a frilled lizard and happened to run across my pond.
Just like that movie.
Anaconda was stupid as fuck.
Like I'd probably read the idea behind it is amazing because there there's some
enormous anacondas in the jungle Brazil that they found so,
and the idea is that there's,
there might be some that are a hundred feet long and your fucking that's
awesome.
See I want to get one of those and just clean house with all my pets and started
wanting to get ahead.
Get to get rid of that.
Right.
That's how you wind up getting the Tigers to get rid of everything else,
right?
Yeah.
Are we ever going to see a gears,
a work connect video game at all?
Oh there's talk about it man.
Cause I know you were against it like in November.
My words,
of course.
I was basically shuffled in to talk to the European press yesterday with
Microsoft.
Right?
And so it's like three Microsoft employees and then me and the Microsoft and
please God bless him,
he could tell they're very media trade.
Well this is what we're doing with connect and they do a good job with it.
And I come in and I'm like man my job is fucking awesome.
I think connect is cool.
Whatever,
right.
And,
uh,
there was talk of it,
but the problem is,
is if you look at the way gears is development cycle was if we were to put it
in,
it would have been totally tacked in.
Like,
Oh,
you can play it with connecting.
If you move your head a little Marcus,
his head moves.
Wow.
Right.
And it's like,
dude,
like if you're going to do it,
design the fucking game for it,
right.
Like uh,
Molyneux and uh,
the,
the fable guys,
how would you make a move forward?
You would,
you'd have to start from the ground up,
right?
Like you,
you'd have to,
it's like,
it's like infinity blade for the IPAD.
We didn't want to do like dual analog sticks on an iPad because that fucking
sucks.
So we're like tap,
tap,
Swipe.
That's what works.
Angry birds,
a fruit Ninja,
all that stuff,
right?
Yeah.
Which I played on connect last night,
which is fucking awesome.
I was like,
that's a good game for it.
How would you get a guy to walk though?
How would you get to go?
I can't hear this dude right there.
Turn Up.
I did.
I just did.
I can hear you.
You can hear me just turn off your phone.
It comes and it goes for some reason there's like a disconnect here.
You have to first and foremost design the pace of the game for it.
So it's not like an intense pixel head first person shooter or whatever.
Right?
You maybe make something,
it's a little bit more adventure,
like a little bit more missed,
like where you kind of explore and then you kind of gesture like you know,
it was kind of,
you know,
move,
move forward and then kind of,
you know,
like you're kind of like maybe your character is kind of driven by the breeze of
the wind and you're kind of guiding the wind and maybe it's kind of like that
game flower and that kind of thing.
Right?
I fucking audio is going all over the board here.
You can design anything for that.
Any kind of interface.
As long as you designed the right game,
be a touchscreen,
be a connect,
be a move,
be at anything,
right?
You just have to step back and build it for it.
Right?
You play Mario Galaxy Mario Galaxy too.
I wasn't a fan of it.
Really careful.
This is sacred ground.
Your,
I see the problem is I um,
I don't like that.
And the we controller at all.
I hate the,
we just because of the controller you late and no,
no.
I mean it's just,
I,
it's just too much for me.
I liked the ps three,
the Xbox controller for the most part.
I think that's just what I'm used to for people don't know what is the
difference?
Well the,
we have like a nun chuck and you have this whole thing going on and what is the,
we look like?
It's like a long slender little mini controller.
The left with a stick and then the right is like,
it looks like a remote control and like to hold a swim at the same time.
They're connected with a string.
And you'll think going to strangle somebody,
right?
Like we were wallet chain or I've never played a single year.
I have it.
I haven't even touched it.
Yeah.
See I like the,
Oh,
I wish that you had the opposite.
See that's the problem.
When you get into like connect and stuff like that.
Cause I would love to be able to play gears of war connect but I have to also
like the option once in a while to lay in bed and not play
the advancements that they unveiled yesterday at the press conferences that you
can play.
You know,
the whole connecting with all the motion sensor but you can do it on your couch
now she can sit there and do this kind of stuff and the finger controls.
So they showed this really sweet demo where this guy was sitting there and
drawing those uh,
like it was like Verizon commercials where they were moving the light and kind
of with the long exposure and kind of creating those shapes.
And he was like drawing this little like a spark pattern with his finger.
And then he rotated his hips and it kind of it around to show it looked pretty
cool.
I'm going to draw a Dick so and have the dad.
The other thing they unveiled with a ted to connect Cameron,
you can take a little stuffed animal and take a photo of it.
It makes a little animated version of that in the game.
It's pretty high.
That's cool.
Shit.
I love how this technology is starting to the,
to actually recognize us now.
Technology like the connect and the Internet is,
is showing similar abilities of actually identifying you and shaping you out of
the universe and saying,
hmm.
You know,
and that's a good deal.
What are the,
one of the best things you could ever do is to get it is disabled Facebook
notifications because what happens is like you're,
you're a slave to that shit and it's telling you when to read it as opposed to
going and checking in at your leisure.
Right.
Cause it's just a spam to you all fucking day long man.
I know where you are.
Don't even get me started on the locator.
We talked a little bit at the end of privacy last time and how it was like
showing all this a apple iCloud shit that's going on.
I think it's cool cause uh,
you know when you have a fucking iPhone and an iPod and iPad and you don't like
getting iTunes to sync and transfer all that stuff.
Can Be Pretty fucking,
we've lost music multiple times,
right?
Um,
but it's having all the fucking cloud.
Cool.
I mean that's what gaming is.
They wanted to go,
they have this shit called online where it's basically you're playing a video
stream,
right?
And so you don't actually have a hard drive.
It's a little micro console and there's just a video stream that's barely
compressed and there's maybe a little bit of lag.
Not much,
but it works.
And you just play it immediately on demand.
Any game.
And you don't even have to have an insane PC.
You can play the highest end graphic PC experience too.
Cause she goes,
it's video,
it's bacon it out to video.
And so what,
they had all these data centers around and those are the states and it just
goes,
right.
Brian and I were talking about this yesterday and Brian was saying,
uh,
I think it's a real good point.
With everything up in the cloud,
people are going to hack into people's shit somehow or another,
a lot of stuff's going to get all of those,
the numbers that it costs Sony for all that fucking hat.
And unbelievable.
Sony got hacked twice.
Sony got hacked.
Crazy.
It cost them a ton of fucking money there.
The police station entirely session.
Eric was down for like a month and it whole network,
it goes all goes back to that one dude who like hack the ps three and then Sony
tried to sue him because the hackers were pissed off about it.
Right.
So this is by sitting down for a month.
Does that mean kids couldn't get online and play?
Imagine Xbox live,
you just can't,
it doesn't work in entire like virtual good purchasing people playing all the
different games online.
Just done.
There are games that could not have their Beta because the shit was down like in
the gears.
Beta was huge for us.
Right.
For testing it.
It took them off the market essentially for a whole month and then they came
back and had to give free games to everybody.
Yeah,
I shit load.
It's like a vehicle but also everybody's credit card numbers got compromised.
Right.
Well apparently they were.
So the stuff is being stored and like texts off our mat or something too,
which is kind of
like injecting coated.
That's the rumor.
Yeah.
And there's still just,
that's ridiculous.
And these people are on Twitter just talking about it every day now it's so
weird that that,
that all this money is taken and all this identity and these guys can just be on
Twitter,
go like,
Hey I'm going to,
do you want us to do Sony,
Brazil next or the future of terrorism is Cybermen it's,
and that's why I love to connect because now our,
my whole house is scanned with my connect,
you know,
so they have like a blueprint in my whole entire thing.
They could turn it on and listen to them.
We turned the connect around for that weeping.
It's,
it's the equivalent of light and gentle slap [inaudible] turn the connector,
take taking a photo of your parents and kind of putting that down.
And I do like how they connect does move up and down too.
I didn't know that cause I just had it sitting on my TV and it flew off.
I'm like,
what the fuck just happened?
And I noticed that it did.
It's following you.
It's a head.
It's a robot.
It's watching any Roebuck and approving of your moves is going to be a video
game,
right?
Don't you think there'll be a fuck video game?
Oh you,
you,
they'll scan your body and then you'll both look hot as fuck in the video game.
You remember the whole teledildonics thing to watch yourself.
Fuck.
And it does what you're doing,
but it's actually people that are hot.
We just put like,
just don't look at each other ever.
Fleshlight integration and you only look at the screen.
I fucking,
last time you busted that flashlight out and you pulled the main rubbery thing
out and the water dripping off of it,
like don't do it.
Don't fucking know.
I just,
I was thinking about that.
That probably is the future of pornography.
What's that?
That's the future that to do,
to have like a virtual relation peel ritual,
hot person that moves the way you move and so you can watch this instead of this
disgusting person you're married to guy or girl.
You can watch this super hot male or female doing to you,
everything that's happening in real life,
but you're seeing it on the screen.
Yup.
So when you flip over and she's gone doggy style like,
and she's not looking at you and you're not looking at how you both look at the
screen and you're seeing what you're actually doing.
But it's hot people.
But that's more for dudes because dudes are visually
oriented.
Right?
You don't think girls are slightly visually oriented.
But if you get a stack rank,
that shit gave up the option to have Ashton Kutcher bone in you or you know,
cause it definitely,
or Brock Ashton Kutcher,
he's got some Nice La douce double going on there.
I don't know.
Brian does.
That's lazy.
That's donor right there.
Yeah.
I just shaved my beard led douche doubles.
Just a little more manicured dude.
It's so fucking funny.
Whatever.
Met these conferences and we yo,
you stay like,
you know like the standard or the W or whatever.
Right.
Those are the worst.
You're hanging out and like I love it when like it's my people,
right.
I could spot the gaming people and were,
you know,
they're trashed.
Journalists are like,
what's up?
I love your shit man.
I'm like,
cool man.
Right.
It's cool.
It's what's up.
And then there's always the last day of the conference where everybody gets out
of town because I have to go to the east coast.
I have to stay that last night.
And he could just see like when the dude she's come back in.
Right.
It's like all of the dazzled shirts and shit.
Shit.
Those ed hardy fucking glitter shirts.
Who thought that was good?
The Florida Lee Dude,
they took,
they took a symbol floor delete Orleans French thing.
Right.
It's a French Canadian thing and it sets Lawrence from New Orleans and she's a
year and the number one tattoo all if he ever gets that fucking flirted.
Liam,
what does it stand for though?
I'm not actually sure.
Something French.
Yes,
it's Franci.
Well I know Randy couture has it tattooed on his arm too.
I'm going to get my ass kicked for saying that now.
Thanks to [inaudible] understand what it was for.
I might have a heritage thing.
Right.
As far as French Canadian or it might be a,
you know,
as far as the French New Orleans type thing.
Have you been to that city man?
New Orleans?
Yeah,
a long time ago.
We need to go back.
He was only there for a UFC.
I was there.
I didn't get to see it.
When you're in town for that stuff,
do you,
I mean you do your show,
you do UFC in new jet.
It depends.
It depends on how much time I have.
You know,
sometimes I get there a day or like Vancouver,
I get there a day early because I have a show on Thursday so I'll do Thursday
night,
Friday nights.
I'll stop you there for three nights.
Okay.
You come back to Charlotte chance to check it out?
No,
I don't have anything booked in Charlotte.
Bummer.
You love that place.
I know you still love living in North Carolina.
I do,
man.
Very Green.
I love it because I get to travel all the fucking time.
Right.
Like Ifr,
the sleepy little southern town cause making video games.
It's not always hanging out.
Doing podcasts like this and fucking hanging out with ice tea.
You sit behind a fucking TV or computer monitor and you do email or you're
sitting in a test lab plane of broken game going,
fuck,
this sucks.
Why are we done yet?
Right.
Bunch of people must figure out the cliffy be from epic games lives in our town
and that must be a weird thing.
You must be that weird guy.
It gets weird because you're in a little tiny ass town and you're driving around
in a fucking Lamborghini.
You're,
you're that guy.
I'm not going to lie.
The car has not gotten old.
The brothers always yell at me.
How does yell yellow?
You're sitting there at the top down and mind my own business.
Just show it.
Also just relaxing.
I was like,
Yo.
I'm like,
fuck,
what's up man?
I'm like,
dude,
don't scares the shit out of me every fucking time.
Right?
People driving by it,
they're like,
they were like following me and they think that they also want to race too and
like you don't have 30 fucking six years old.
I got a lot to lose here.
I'm not being thrown in jail for fucking drag racing down Glenwood fucking
avenue.
Like seriously.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
I don't get the racing shit.
I don't bet
I've done it.
Really?
Sure.
What are you driving it for?
I have a gt three,
a Porsche gt three cools my favorite car.
I fucking,
dude,
I'm,
I'm not,
I don't want to wrap my shit around a treatment.
Yeah,
I don't do that either,
but I've done it.
I knew a guy in town.
You fucking did that ever.
It's rappers miles ride around a tree fucking dive or from the cops,
right?
Oh Jesus.
I think it's just a certain type of guy who,
who cannot go out who you,
if,
if you get a nice car like that and you like to go out and drink,
you can't bring the fucking car.
Right.
Because it's not gonna end well.
And you're like so insecure and you need to park the car outside the fucking
club,
dude.
Like really what your car is up to the whole time,
you have to put your keys in the bar.
Like what's up?
How's it going?
Right.
But yeah,
it's fun in that town though,
Dude.
Um,
like when,
you know,
I did Fallon,
like the bars I go to all head to the show on and everything like that.
Right.
And um,
it's tiny though.
I'll tell you the dating scene is fucking horrible.
I'm sure it's monsters,
right?
And uh,
but North Carolina monsters,
you believe in Jesus.
People are cool.
I need to know before this goes,
North Carolina is a great state and
you go 20 minutes outside of town.
It gets really fucking scary.
Texas.
I Love Austin.
What if you drive 20 minutes outside of Austin to just drag and black people
behind trucks?
Once you see a fucking cracker,
once a cracker barrel shows up,
fucking run.
That's my rule.
It's like the end of civilization,
like the cracker barrel and beyond that,
the cracker Trex,
this has got these amazing spots,
these amazing bright lights.
And then as you go deep into the,
you know,
Texas is fucking huge.
I know,
I know.
But as you go deep into those shady,
weird,
barely populated areas,
they're scary as fuck.
Yup.
And there's a math everywhere out there.
All those little lightly populated areas.
Oh,
at one point out here too.
It's like at what point you're like,
I'm going to huff.
That sounds like a fucking,
probably very early.
Some fucking whippets and grow up in Palmdale.
And you know,
Bakersfield Dad's been punching in the face every day since you were six,
you know?
What do you think on the console timeline?
Where do you think we are with the,
like the current generation console?
They're going to try it.
They're gonna ride this.
One of the wheels fall off.
It's like they can write,
well dude,
I'm sitting here like,
you look at some of the shit we haven't gears three and you look at it,
I saw the new tomb raider last night.
We'll look.
It looks really fucking good.
And all the kids in the form,
and it's 2011 they're still making a tomb raider last equals the one that fails
to make money,
dude.
All right.
Yeah.
So the thing is is it looks really good,
right?
And so what they did was Lara Croft no longer looks like a trainee.
Michael Jackson,
she looks like this hot little girl,
right?
And she,
and she puts,
she just looked like a stripper.
She's,
she's attractive,
but she didn't look like a whore and she's like filthy all the time.
Right.
And so I'm sitting there looking at the demo last night and all I can think of
is that scene in grandma's boy with the guys jerking off to the little aircraft
figure.
And he said,
cause she's dirty or in the game,
right?
It's,
you're a dirty girl there
and it's fucking brutal.
Like she's,
she's on this island with these fucking savages and like they keep trying to
grab it,
right.
It's like a little cutie.
Like you're going to get raped and he had x to not get raped.
Right.
And the grabbing and it takes like a fucking actually hits and killed and right
in the fucking head,
man.
It's like brutal.
And like she got crushed by rocks and just die and all these crazy ass ways.
Right.
He gets killed with an axe.
Was it a pick ax or an ax to like a throw to the forehead?
Man,
it was fucking harsh,
man.
Yeah.
I don't think you should have video gangs where women get killed by accident.
You just play them just to lose it.
What's up bro?
Get hacked up.
Loser.
The coppers chop.
I think it was,
could talk.
It was like a,
when you announced girls in gears three,
they're like,
should she be chainsawed I've thought about this for about a beat.
And we're like,
let me tell you the gears for some reason has a lot of female fans.
I don't fucking know why right now we haven't lockable pink guns just for shits
and giggles.
Right?
It's even better if I kill you and have a pink gun.
It's an inner,
he was way better.
And uh,
and I guarantee if you were to take any of those fans of the game and the girls
and be like,
you can't get chain saw the big fuck that I don't want to chance.
I'd like everybody else.
I want you to curb stuck in my head,
right?
So when you see this locus creature stand over little blonde on Ya and rip off
her fucking arm and beat her to death with it.
Yeah.
It's like
evil dead violence.
Right.
He's not like,
he's not like climbing on top of her and gouging out her fucking eyeballs.
Right.
It's comedic.
Beating somebody does with their own fucking arm.
Really?
Yeah.
It's not legible.
It's not going to inspire someone to go out and do that.
No.
I would argue the opposite is true.
That someone who might be inclined to do that might find vicarious pleasure
through the argument that Japan uses.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
a lot of people
believe that and then it makes sense to me.
It makes sense that there needs to be some sort of outlet.
I bet if you could get like porn and flashlights in prison,
I bet rapes would drop dramatically.
It's such a fucking fan.
I'm sitting there.
Um,
so we were hanging out with ice and he had a couple of boys and they're talking
about it.
He's like,
yeah,
he did three,
he did five and I'm like,
I would be fucked in prison.
I'd have three a year.
So cage.
And that's such a weird mentality.
We take it,
you know,
straight men and put them all together and get matter of time,
they're going to fuck dude.
Right.
It's so popular in the Mexican community that called gay for the stay.
Have like a
movie with Edward James Olmos.
Yeah,
I remember they were all gay for each other.
Yeah.
Well apparently that's just the way it is.
You know,
like these guys just accepted.
That's like the gay for pay.
The guys who just do gay porn just for the money.
Right?
Yeah.
I don't ever buy that,
man.
I remember I read that there's a guide that they were talking about that did
that years ago,
and there was a story in Esquire and I was,
I remember reading it going,
this is fucking
Peter North did a gay porn.
Yes.
An orgasm.
Fucking man.
You're probably gay.
Why is your Dick hard dude fucking hangup.
Yeah.
I'm pretending to be gay right now.
They're only gay for pay if they never come.
Yeah.
Well,
you have to this to get your money.
You got to get paid [inaudible] shot.
No,
I don't want to see that.
It's not a good dude.
It was the same story as the movie,
but the ratchet it up there,
there's fucking lady boys in there.
They shut the whole nine yards and Helms gets fucked by a lady by,
sorry to spoil the movie.
What the fuck dude,
spoiler alert.
He had his,
where he's talking to his,
his,
he's like,
I got a demon in me and Zach Alphadex is just like,
you've got to see me in yet.
They show up at this bar,
they're trying to figure out what happened and you see this girl and you're
looking at it.
She looks like a dude version of Nicole Scherzinger from the pussycat dolls.
Right.
And I'm like,
I look at Lauren,
I'm like,
it's a lady boy.
She's like,
what?
I'm like,
wait for it.
And eventually she's like,
she's not,
it's not called Bangkok,
it's called,
it's not called bank cons.
It's called Bangkok.
And should they show the fucking lady boy dick just like right out there,
right.
Not only is it like you thinking he fucked her in the ass,
but no,
she plowed him in the ass.
And then she's like,
yeah,
and then,
you know,
I came and you came in the floor.
That's how it was.
I was just like,
this is a number one opening rated r movie in America in 2011.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Right?
There's a lot of Dick in movies these days and you notice that I shouldn't try
not to.
Ever since,
uh,
forgetting Sarah Marshall,
there's just full frontal Dick Everywhere.
It's so loud.
But you can't show vaginas yet.
You can't insert sheep aren't ready for that because Dick's or funny,
especially when they're not,
when they're hard,
they're totally different than it's threatening.
It's like,
no,
there's no two different vaginas,
vaginas,
vaginas.
But there's two different things though.
The baboons in flame,
he posts sex vagina's different,
little blown out one,
right?
I don't know what kind of damage you're doing.
I want to back off.
A little might be ruined and something son get a little pinker,
but Dick's,
you know,
there's,
there's quite a,
there's quite a difference between the flacid in the hard dude.
You know,
I remember I was threatened.
I saw 28 days later in the theater.
Right.
There's the opening scene.
Fucking awesome movies.
See Cillian Murphy.
He sees Dick for like two seconds.
I was in the theater enough time for you.
I needed,
I need hours.
I need miles up.
Dik Dik Dik dik dik dik all the time.
You,
oh,
I,
that's a good ring.
Turn right there guys.
Cut that part out.
[inaudible]
Harvey Keitel was reservoir dogs.
My whole point is about the American cycling.
People walked out of the fucking theater because of the day,
just because of the two seconds a day.
Walked out of the theater.
I was in Laverne,
California.
That's a Dick Junkie.
That's what they just showed him a line of meth and he could take it.
That's what that looks.
That line,
but tower level payments.
It's your point about interracial porn in the south.
Right.
I quoted that to ist the other day.
He thought that was fucking funny.
Man.
That's never in my life.
Did I think I'd be quoting Joe to ice?
What the fuck man?
Right.
Do everything.
We'll see like old school,
like when Webcam is first came back on a are into video games where you used to
be able to like take a photo of your face and it puts you on like a Tony Hawk
characters.
Oh Dude,
we're going to see that again.
But I'm sure it's some of the working on that kind of stuff for connect so that
I can put my balls on my character's face.
Exactly.
Our gears of war.
Cause like you think with the connect,
like paste a bunch of Dicks to your head in the game and I can run around a
million.
Well you have a meter that fills up and they're all flashing.
You unleashed the rage now I'll go [inaudible] yeah,
why not?
It would probably have some dick detector to make sure done.
We've thought it up
right now.
Someone else beat us to it.
Somebody else thought about doing that and probably just done it.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that subset of Japanese pornography where it's like the girls being torn apart
while they're shitting and alien with a Coptic posters with dicks and stuff.
I was in fucking Akihabara.
Uh,
in Japan they have these little shops that are like,
the stairways are only so wide that one person can make it through and it's
these little porn stores and there's like six floors in the first floor is just
kind of like,
you know,
little school girls naked and as you go up it gets worse and worse and worse.
It's like the dark days and Ferno levels of hell and you get to the top and it's
like stuff you can't unsee.
You're like,
what subset?
Like it's the same thing with like the David Carradine shit where like,
you know,
the auto Rocky's fixation,
right.
At what point is jerking off that boring?
Yeah.
You need to almost die to make it fun.
Or they killed David Carradine and said,
what's the best way to kill this guy?
Make it look completely ridiculous.
Well,
it's just them,
his dick out put them in a fucking wetsuit.
You know,
I wrote to make him look like a pre,
there was a priest that died.
It was a,
he had,
uh,
a black dildo up his ass.
He was wearing a full scuba wet suit and he stuffed this dildo up his ass and
then died and strangled to death while I'm autoerotic UK's we've seen,
the first thing I thought of is if I was going to kill a priest that molested
me,
I would probably do is choke them to death and then hang him and then put a
black dildo up his ass and put them in a fucking wetsuit and love the adjective.
It's not pink one,
it's not a poker one who was black?
Black Dildo is deep up his ass and the drink.
I want to make the black cock and you get a double story like straight up,
extra stiff.
Right?
I guarantee you that's a murderer.
I guarantee you that's an unsolved murder.
The preacher with a jerking off one day and he's like s and then like cut the
four is six months later and he's got the deal.
When he's asked,
he's like,
it's not fucking working wet suit to me.
Like there's an easier way to choke yourself if you had like a tie and just
started twisting it.
Yeah.
Cause once you,
once you're fixing it to something they need to needed,
it never ends well just about the suicide in it,
in the act I think,
you know,
they're not trying to kill themselves.
Well no,
but the having an orgasm is like a,
you know the French call it a little bit of like linking the two together.
So close is a ups the ante.
Uh,
not that I know.
Yeah.
You get a little red around your neck.
Hit us with a,
a psychological point that I never ever considered.
There's always one kid in high school that like dyes that way and it's gotta be
hard enough to lose a kid.
But imagine fucking coming home and finding that like should just use one.
It was like blood pressure,
things like wrap up on your arm that you can give free like at cvs.
Just wear it around your neck and it's turn it on,
maybe squeeze and then it kills you.
It doesn't that go.
You gotta let that thing go.
You better off with the Thai twist,
the tie until you're about to go out and then,
but with the,
with the blood and once you're letting go the tile on Ralph multitasking so
you're not only keeping track of your health.
Yeah.
And then you keep track and to get an accurate meeting.
He got you digging your hand fingers up,
your ass going to be able to,
he's not your normal resting heart rate.
Elevated.
Still excited,
but I think the more safety,
yeah,
I think you got a point there.
I think there's something about the choking yourself,
the hanging where you're like,
I'm so dirty.
I'm hanging while beating off with a wetsuit on honeybadger.
He don't give a shit that's best internet me and fucking,
it's one of my favorite watch out that that bird,
I'm like,
that guy needs a development deal right now for the discovery channel.
I will post.
Part of that video is in the honeybadger fucks up the Cobra but gets stung.
And so he,
he's eating it and then he blacks out from all the venom and he's laying there
looking like a fat Al Bundy dirty covered in dirt laying there with his stomach
up in the air and then shakes out of it and an hour later and just fucks that
snake up.
Then I'm just went right through his fucking insane.
A little system.
So you think about it in the grand scheme of like nineties video,
we had a fucking at Ku to hedgehog.
Where was the fucking honeybadger I know they fucked.
That goes back to the neo problem.
You could not make them video game about a fucking honeybadger cause he can not
be killed.
And he takes everything down.
Like what's the Kryptonite to fucking honey badger?
They fuck up cobras grows the stinging and go have bitch.
What about that?
He's like,
fine.
Or some shit.
Like fuck you lion the lion [inaudible] yeah,
everything's afraid of those.
He's like the Joe Pesci,
the animal kingdom.
Little fucker came to share.
Really.
It's another bad ass wolverines.
Even larger.
That movie was on TV yesterday.
The fucking expert origins one that those,
so the ends of the big mortal combat fighters get horrible man.
You're on top like some shit I would pitch.
It's like,
all right,
so we've combined all of their fucking powers into one unit.
It's Ryan Reynolds by the way,
and his mouth is shut so we can't talk,
get it.
And he's got all the powers and that it's fucking beast and wolverine in a three
player fight on top of a nuclear cooling tower.
Go like,
Nah Dude.
Excellent.
First class supposed to be good though.
Have you seen this new we you that I was just an ad.
They actually go there.
They unveil it.
Everybody on the Twitter feeds bagging on the name,
but it's like,
dude,
they will make the name cool.
Like you like Thor.
Uh,
actually I wanted to hate it but I thought it was really good.
I thought Thor was fun.
It's fun.
It's fucking great.
He's the area,
the area and barbarian I bought into it.
It works.
Yup.
They committed to it,
but they had it up for that.
Like we were just like,
Oh yeah,
I'm a Thor.
Then they tase him.
Right.
And then I was like,
I liked this drink.
This is delicious.
And he fucking smash it with a cup.
Right.
I liked that.
I was,
I thought it was big robot thing too.
Yeah.
The
green lantern.
Like why don't remember the green lanner being awesome.
They're kind of scraping the bottom of the barrel superheroes right now.
Like,
isn't it weird?
You can't come up with a new one?
What's the last,
the last one I can remember?
Fucking spawn.
Yes.
Kick ass.
Why did they stop making spawns?
Remember the,
because the tool needs to do for HBO.
So that was good.
What was wrong with the movie?
I didn't mind in the,
in
my opinion.
Yeah,
it's Michael.
Jai White is a friend of mine,
so I liked the movie.
You remember the,
uh,
the,
when she start knowing people in entertainment,
it's such a nice guy.
He's one of the nicest guys in the world.
My buddy Gary widow used to edit PC gamer magazine and he wrote book of Eli.
He's like posting photos of him at Danville.
Like what's up?
And I'm going into this like,
fuck,
I hope this is fucking good.
It's actually pretty fucking good film right
to the end.
And you're like,
wait,
what?
He was blind.
What?
That's the Bible.
Get the Fuck Outta here with dad.
You gotta have you damn dirty orbs.
You're ruined it all moment.
Right.
So you look at like Matthew,
you looking at Mark Miller,
Mark Miller and some of those comic book writers are doing it right now.
For some reason the studios don't want to bet on a lot of it cause kickass was
fucking great man.
The whole watchman was great too.
It was good.
Um,
apparently I didn't get to see sucker punch.
It wasn't,
I loved the Watchman v for vendetta to,
that was terrific shit.
Son fucking days.
The most Dixie ever see on digital space Dick Right there and they,
a real dick graphic novel is even better than the movie.
Tough week alert.
Yeah,
it's true though.
I mean you have to do graphics,
fancy comic books,
graphic novels with my actions
figures.
This is a real novel.
Those clips,
you have to go back to [inaudible].
I gotta go be cooped up in a booth like veal p and journalists to go.
Can you tell me if I give it to soc
across the table and fucking strangle them?
Yeah,
you're quite the impression is this,
the,
you showed a side of yourself today on this podcast that you didn't allow.
That was a drama nerd in high school.
While you're,
you're much more loose with your impressions today.
We appreciate it.
Thank you for talking about Dicks and making me feel loose.
Dude.
Thank you for coming over and being with us for an hour before you got to do
your official duties.
Cliff would be,
he's an awesome dude.
I've known cliffy forever.
We've known each other for like 10 years now.
We're all dude,
he's a cool guy.
Very cool guy.
Follow him on Twitter.
Uh,
the real cliffy B and a and if anybody wants to get gears of war,
that's easy.
You know where the fuck to get that shit.
Just don't rent it,
buy it,
don't buy it.
That comes with a gears of war one and two it comes with a you against a dude's
resell on their shit on Ebay and stuff like that.
If you're a dude reselling your shit,
it is what it is in the stuff's been a good partner as far as like launching the
game,
but three quarters of their businesses,
he used games,
man once.
If you buy a used game,
you're not our customer.
You're right.
Right.
So and so what's happening is everybody's moving to these games as service
movements and getting online and everything like that.
So big box retail,
how much can they save if they buy a used game stuff,
we'll buy that shit from you for you buy for $60 day one they bought used for
like five or 10 and then they resell it for 50 it's bullshit.
Really?
Yeah.
Why?
For five bucks and resell it.
When a
playstation two I wanted to get our places,
whatever.
I wanted to get a new playstation three and I was like,
how much is it used when they were like,
ah,
it's the two 79 I'm like,
how much does a new and two 99 like what the fuck to call her?
Right?
Can't complain
about this because I drive a Lamborghini.
So if I could wait,
you wind up looking like Lars.
All right,
remember Lars Lars,
you live in a fucking castle in the sky,
which shut the fuck up.
Just completely ridiculous it that that fucked him man.
Because everybody said,
well,
this guy is super fucking greedy.
Yup.
But your point stands.
I mean,
it makes a lot of sense,
but the thing,
the thing to keep in mind is forget about the fact that,
you know,
I've been doing this inside 17 bleeding out of the eyeballs to do it.
I'd like to think I earned when I fucking have,
right.
That said,
if this trend continues,
you're not going to see as many AAA games because the money's not coming in for
the budget for the fucking game has.
Because these guys,
his game flaw and all these different guys that sell used things.
Have you seen a tangible drop off in sales because of this?
Uh,
so gears to sold over 6 million copies and we know how many unique user ids
touched Xbox live of it.
I don't want to give numbers,
but it's significant.
Would you be more in favor of a rental sort of market where I'm wondering why.
I'm wondering why,
why Microsoft and Sony eight don't actually have their own rental boxes and say
resell the shit to us.
But the key,
they all,
the only way we can get past that as to make a game that gamers Marion don't
date,
right?
They make a game that they fucking play forever.
A cereal.
I don't think most guys even consider the economic impact of it.
I think they look at it and they say,
well,
I'm going to save 20 bucks buy button to use.
When I was like,
you know,
I'm,
I'm looking at my bank account when I was working at Mcdonald's and I could take
out $20 intervals and I had $43 I was like,
sweet.
I have two withdrawals left.
I mean,
that's how it is when you're young.
Right?
Basically what you're saying is do what you gotta do,
but if you can make a choice please by the,
and hopefully we'll make the game that justifies what we call a day fucking one
purchase.
Right?
The key to doing it,
it's buy it off Amazon and Amazon's always,
I'm on a deal.
I don't really think so.
I go to the store for an hour or a fucking clothing and food.
Everything else is online.
Yeah.
I'm a huge online shopper.
One quick,
one quick one.
So easy.
You can buy whatever sneaker you're looking for.
Black Dildos,
all our podcasts,
stuff you get by it all.
You guys have fleshlight hooked me up by the way.
Oh,
here you got.
Why you taking your fucking users that new?
That's the new debt.
That's very kind.
There's an industry that will not be affected by you sales anytime.
[inaudible]
that off the table fetish that comes up.
How do we stop the use market to start Victoria's secret doesn't have to deal
with the,
even the question would be like a Brian red band question.
Okay.
How do we stop them from selling used ones as masturbate on when we would just
go dude,
shut up.
The meeting would continue.
All right.
I think we got roll.
Please roll.
Thank you very much for coming.
We'll take a little intermission real quick.
Yeah.
We're to take just a couple of minutes and we'll be back with my boy Johnny
rotten.
He's to my right
where I didn't even notice that.
Where is it in the main living off the,
check it out later.
Have you ever talked to you by walking on the chase to go so she,
he's learned how to hit the start button and just sits there and plays with the
ghost.
The cats just turn off the whole pac man is what I'm saying.
The very top of it.
On the very top left,
there's a power button that you push in on the very top.
Nevermind.
Just lit.
That's all right.
Just push the button down.
There's a hole right there,
right where you left hand is
check
Johnny.
J.
O.
N.
Y.
Crystal.
Yeah.
Hello.
We're back with a different configuration on the video screen.
If you're watching on Ustream,
don't be confused.
It's the same show.
This is my pal Johnny Rotten Akhi Christopher Harris,
long time old school friend from back in the days we interdimensionally traveled
together.
That's what I'm calling it these days.
I think that's what happens.
That's how you got to talk about it because otherwise it's like,
just sounds like you're doing drugs and people can just tell you no,
that didn't happen.
When you talk about,
I'll put that close to you so you can hear yourself better.
So the folks at home,
yeah.
Yeah.
I love that argument.
That doesn't happen.
She's Jewish nation.
Are you sure?
Where are you there?
Yeah.
How the fuck can you be sure.
Who knows what goes on inside the mind.
Who knows?
I mean,
you know,
the idea of chemical,
some sort of a chemical interaction in your mind as being trivial,
not that big a deal.
So that means free thought and form of communication that we have are our words
have no meaning,
nothing has meaning.
If it comes from within your own mind,
you can write it off as being an inconsequential.
That's kind of extreme.
But yeah,
sort of.
Right?
But we know that some things give you hallucinations like so there are things
that you take to give you an image of something that absolutely isn't there.
So the problem is,
you know,
if you're a pragmatist and if you,
he'd go all Ockham's razor on a mother fucker,
you go,
well,
is it more likely that what you're doing is just,
but you know,
but inundating your cerebral cortex with a bunch of chemicals,
it doesn't know how to control.
And so it gives you some faulty signals and you're looking at basically video
artifacts in the mind.
Right?
I think that's exactly what it is.
And I like the,
the true hallucinations.
That's the idea kind of at times because everything is a construct of the mind.
Everything in our universe.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Right.
I mean,
you know,
when you see a guy,
it's always fascinated me to see someone who's obviously completely insane,
like walking down the street,
like some homeless person having a conversation with themselves and you almost
wish you could see what they're seeing.
You know,
it,
what was that movie,
the Fisher King,
the Robin Williams movie with Absolute Geoff Daniel,
Jeff Bridges.
And he played a insane person who like believed he was like fighting like
dragons and it wasn't that what it was.
It was,
it was,
it was about that guy,
you know,
he had a,
there were still a power in his words and his thoughts and you know,
they a lot of craziness around Ma,
the majority of the thoughts he had.
But you know,
that was,
that was a pretty good example of a schizophrenia kind of homeless guy that is,
you know,
has something to contribute to society.
You know,
I don't know that.
I wish I could see what was actually going on in his head.
Well,
I wonder,
you know,
I wonder when you see a guy just completely babbling to himself and talking and
just,
I wonder what he's seeing.
Is it,
is that,
is it that clear?
I mean,
it's obviously there's levels,
right?
We all know someone who's only slightly crazy and you're like,
he's okay,
but he's just kind of crazy.
You know?
It just,
he can't keep it totally together.
And then we know people that are like really,
really rational.
There's,
you know,
there's a,
there's a whole level,
there's a spectrum.
So there's gotta be a spectrum of crazy too.
At the high end of the spectrum.
What is the craziest motherfucker on this planet seeing?
What are they saying?
I mean,
are they going through hobbit world every day fighting off orcs?
it,
was that possible?
Is that what's going on?
That might be pretty fucking bad ass if it was,
you know,
imagine if you,
everybody thought you were completely crazy,
so they fed you and they kept you in some sort of an institution somewhere.
But in your mind,
you were off on a fucking adventure superhero.
Yeah.
Everyday.
Was Conan the barbarian,
the new version better than a desk job,
I guess that's watching some murders show last night was like la homicide or
something like that.
It's about murders and La.
It's kind of like a mystery show and they actually showed the body like laying
on the ground is weird when you watch
a TV show and they actually showed dead bodies and stuff and murder scenes.
Yeah.
I don't like that shit.
Yeah,
it's creepy.
But uh,
they were talking about the wife is the murdered the husband and the wife was
starting to lose.
Her mind started to go crazy and when they were interviewing her,
they were like,
first part she,
she started to make sense and then she would say like,
yeah,
I started stabbing him,
but then all these tomatoes came out of his stomach and you're just like,
wow,
can you imagine that word?
Like you're half mixing real stuff with like,
you think you'd see tomatoes coming out of your husband when you're stabbing
him?
Well that's the mental illness is the inability to,
or I guess one form of mental illness is to define reality properly and
correctly.
You know,
you don't always know what's properly correct.
Well it's about the use of your sentences and how you process that information
into a,
an understanding and then she's the one who's right.
Maybe there are tomatoes coming out of that.
What the fuck are,
we just can't see them.
Maybe it's delicious.
Maybe these people are in touch with a different dimension,
you know,
like maybe a,
at least in form of consciousness.
Well that's one of the reasons why the,
when they first started,
uh,
you know,
many of the cycle psychedelic studies that have taken place when they first
started doing it,
we haven't lights.
Oh,
sexy,
romantic.
Um,
when you know,
they,
they did a lot of studies with psychedelics where they were trying to figure out
if they would help people that were crazy or whether they were drugs.
It doesn't seem like schizophrenia.
Totally area.
I think that if you're really,
if you're having a hard time with regular reality,
you're having a hard time like keeping shit together and then all of a sudden
you get blasted on mushrooms.
That shit I could take you deep over the,
you know,
over the rainbow and clippy was here we were talking about Colton sort of
leaders of they can fixate people on an idea or a thought and sometimes,
uh,
psychedelics can help you overcome those fixations that,
that you can develop in your own mind around a certain,
you know,
impression of yourself that you have or you know,
a way of seeing the world and you've never overcome that.
And it can be a stoppage in a,
a way of blocking your progress.
And it was,
you know,
blasting through that with psychedelics can dorsal or you could lose your
fucking marbles.
You could be barely hanging on and you do a massive dose of acid.
Everybody knows that one dude who never came back from absolutely.
No,
we all heard about him when we were in high school.
You know,
it's always the acid acid or mushrooms,
I guess.
Even Mckenna,
his brother Dennis,
and when they went down in South America,
his brother lost his fucking mind for two whole weeks and they wrote about it in
the sessions.
Yeah.
I mean he just,
he did,
he did so much mushrooms that reality was obliterated and he was,
you know,
essentially a crazy person for two weeks.
I also think that you have to,
to even dabble in things like that,
you kind of have to have a strong consciousness originally so you can
reconstruct the world is you start sobering up for work experience.
And to me that's always been what it's about is not the moment where I'm
hallucinating and seeing,
thinking I'm communicating with,
you
know,
a multidimensional entities.
But it's about afterwards and sort of coming back into myself and then,
yeah,
well if you can't live in me,
you're one of those people that has to trip all the time and you can't live in
this dimension where you're missing the whole point.
The whole point of any psychedelic experience or even like intense yoga methods,
you know,
like,
intense Kundalini Yoga.
The whole idea is that you can bring something back from that state.
You know,
you don't want to put yourself in the state of Yoga Bliss all day and just only
exist in the Ashram.
You want to go out and fucking and you and utilize any lessons that you've
learned from any sort of a psychedelic experience,
whether it's isolation tank or drugs or whatever.
You want to be able to integrate that into your life.
It takes you someplace.
It is a real trip.
That's why they call it a trip.
It takes you someplace,
but I think not many people try actively to bring something back from that
place.
You know,
have to learn something from it and you have to be able to,
to you,
well,
you don't have to,
you can do whatever the fuck you want.
Why am I saying half too?
But I think as the most value though,
yeah,
I think there's the most value in learning something from it and bringing that
back,
learning something about yourself.
And then trying to,
you know,
take whatever weird,
exposing a experience you had,
I really like tuned you into your own reality and you gotta you gotta take that
and then be a better person with it,
you know,
take that and utilize whatever lesson you've learned from it and then you're
doing something good with psychedelics,
then psychedelics seem to make sense.
Then there's no argument against it.
But some people don't do that.
You know,
it's all about balance.
if you're,
if you're imbalanced and you know you're doing psychedelics,
you know,
you're,
you're likely to get even more imbalanced.
It's,
you know,
it might,
it might jolt you into some sort of a state of a self awareness,
but it might not to your mind.
Well,
I think your point earlier too,
that,
you know,
these,
these kind of things are easy to argue against as being just a hallucination,
a chemical flood if hallucinations.
But when you go into the experience with that kind of attitude that,
well,
whether it's real or not,
I'm going to experience something real at the time.
And it's about how you process it afterwards.
A lot of people block it out of their memory.
You know,
if you ask them what their trip was like,
they'll kind of give you this standardized answer.
But the ego is healed over the wound.
If you ever seen a tree that got hit by lightning,
I saw a tree that got hit by lightning.
It was at the Boston Science Museum and this tree got fucked up in a fire.
And uh,
after the fire was over,
uh,
the,
the fire got put out before the tree burnt down.
So the tree her,
this big ass hole in it and the tree over hundreds of years,
true is like thousands of years old.
It was a huge section of the tree.
The,
the edges of the tree were curling over to fill in the hole to like heal over
the wound.
And I think your ego does that.
I think when your ego takes a devastating blow from psychedelics and you know,
you just g reality gets obliterated,
boundaries dissolve,
and you start to look at your existence as you know,
a as a,
a much less selfish and much more involved thing.
And this,
this,
this weird connection that we have to every aspect of our lives.
It's weird,
you know,
fiber that runs through the universe,
that,
that pulses through our own reality.
Sometimes it's too much for people.
So you come back and then you just start fucking drinking and partying and
yelling at your ex girlfriend.
And the next thing you know,
you're,
you're back in the negative grind.
You've replayed all of your behavior patterns and you're,
you're right back to square one.
So it's like every jolt of psychedelics,
every psychedelic experience,
every jolt of perception.
All it does is like,
gets you,
gives you a little window and you've got to move forward.
Go,
go,
go.
You take your new position.
Okay,
wait for the next one,
learn and then wait for the next one.
Then the next one at another window opens up and go,
whoa.
Some guys don't go through that door though.
Some guys,
the window opens up and go,
no,
I'm good.
I'm going to say it right here.
I'm gonna just pee all over myself.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
um,
I think there's a,
there's something really valuable to them.
That's why we talk about them all the time.
You know,
people say it's so silly.
You're talking about,
uh,
you know,
the psychedelics and all these different experiences that you have,
the isolation tank.
You talk about it all the time.
Why are you talking about it all the time?
Talk about it all the time because it's fucking fascinating all the time.
To me,
if you're experiencing these things,
it would be the topic of your normal conversation on a regular basis because
they're so hyper realistic.
It's hyper reality.
It's just different way of observing and analyzing your,
your own position in this dementia and the fact that people don't take advantage
of it.
It might very well be responsible for our evolution.
I agree.
I mean in that we're tribal people by nature as cliff,
he was talking,
you know,
the gamers hang out together,
hang out together,
the Internet geeks hang out together.
And uh,
you know,
having these shared experiences that run throughout your tribe or a form of,
I guess a rite of passage that it's actually missing those sorts of things,
rites of passage into adulthood and sharing an experience that was traumatic but
meaningful and gives you an ability to discuss something intelligently as a
commonality.
That's a rite of passage that doesn't exist in widespread culture in America
anymore.
And we've lost that connection is tribal individuals to,
to nurture the,
the,
uh,
child into adulthood.
And for me,
that's when I use psychedelics the most.
I mean,
as I'm an adult with a lot going on in my life,
I,
I don't really do it anymore to be honest.
That not very often at least.
And it was tough when you have responsibilities to chalk off six hours,
we'll,
you'll be unavailable and actually and tired the next day.
But,
but I mean it was also for me,
it kind of passage into a,
how I view the world is,
you know,
kind of seeing,
uh,
the other side of sanity but also a reconstructing something with that
experience behind me and talking about it with people like you and my other
friends who we,
you know,
engaged in that kind of activity.
And,
you know,
it was very meaningful for how I see the world today.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's really interesting what we're talking about,
this rite of passage thing,
because I was just talking to my friend Justin the other night,
we were playing pool Justin from the actual report.com and we were playing pool
when we were talking about how people in this country,
in this day and age don't have like a,
uh,
a rite of passage don't have something that makes you a man.
And that's probably something culturally that exists because you need to know
like,
okay,
I'm a man now,
you know?
Okay,
I just got my black belt in life.
I'm a man now.
You know what I'm saying?
Like there needs to be some sort of a ceremony or there's this positive
affirmation that now I am a man.
It's like your joke.
We never really become adults because we don't have those rites of passage that
define us.
I think though,
rice of right,
a real rite of passage and doing something really difficult,
you know,
and realizing that you can,
there's so few people that realize their own potential in it,
just enjoying things on this earth because they don't really know what their
limitations are.
What does that,
that marijuana is bad for you?
Um,
you know,
I think that's a,
I,
that's something that maybe people need to rethink,
but you know,
they just kind of drift through a linear form of consciousness from the day
they're born to the day their hormones takeover and adolescence.
And,
you know,
there's nothing to define them as adults and pass that experience.
I just,
yeah,
it's unfortunate.
And all you think about is getting out of school,
married,
no job.
And then,
you know,
I remember being a volume on or something.
I remember being,
um,
like uh,
you know,
uh,
21,
22 years old,
you know,
just having started standup comedy and you know,
and realizing that,
you know,
just completely bewildered by the fact that I was an adult now and totally
responsible for my own actions living on my own,
you know,
traveling around and I was like,
this is so bizarre.
I'm not ready for this.
I shouldn't be looking after myself yet.
I'm just still a child.
You know,
the,
the missing thing,
the big event that lets you know that you're a man,
we need to bring that shit back.
I think we criminalize those behaviors as sort of a European influence over
then.
You know,
this continent is this sort of dominated,
dominating a ideas where if you're doing things as rites of passage amongst your
tribe,
you're not following the greater agenda as a,
you know,
what society dictates is appropriate.
Right.
What would be a way around that?
Would there be a way around that?
Oh,
how could you have a right of passage,
sort of a situation thing and not have everybody freak out and go all David
Koresh risky thing.
Because we started saying,
okay,
we're going to do the Johnny Rotten Joe Rogan cultish.
And it's real simple.
We don't want your money.
We're just going to help everybody.
Yeah.
Nobody would buy that because after a while they were so many kids that would be
like,
so like in Nambour to view and wanting to keep it like,
Johnny,
can I do anything?
And you're like,
yeah,
well you can get me a sandwich.
I really like a sandwich.
And before you know,
it
all changes.
You know,
we're,
we're very malleable,
so fuck.
Yeah,
we are,
man.
I've been having these conversations with,
uh,
you know,
um,
I did this Kevin James movie and talking to one of the producers and he's got a
ton of experience in Hollywood and he was talking to me about all the years and
all the crazy things that he's seen in the movie business.
But one of the,
the standard ones is that once someone becomes like super famous,
especially like a lot of crazy women,
they go nuts and start yelling at people and ordering people around.
Like I hought heard like stories of like Brett Butler on the set of that grace
under fire show being insane and,
and you know,
and this,
this guy and this,
the topic of this conversation was how the,
the power that is bestowed upon them as actors into the love and adulation that
they get.
It's almost,
it's unmanageable and they lose their mind.
They,
they almost can't help losing their mind because they're your,
it's such an unnatural level of love that they get that their,
their whole sense of how they're being perceived and what they're putting out as
far as what they're getting back.
It's completely skewed and they don't see themselves the way other people see
themselves.
We've actually as a culture wired them neurologically.
We've created to be royal to them that their royalty,
they really are like royalty.
I mean,
and some of them are benevolent gods and some,
and some of them are fucking angry.
And,
and you know,
and like,
I don't think we were talking about this with my,
with my friend Justin and I again,
we were talking about Elvis that I always say that I don't think it's possible
to be Elvis and not be crazy.
I think when you get to that Elvis level,
all bets are off.
Dude,
you can't walk out of your house.
Bitches are fucking screaming.
They're screaming for you everywhere.
They must be plotting to figure out a way to suck your Dick.
How do you mean they humble?
How can you ever watch those videos when he was on stage and they were going
fucking crazy screaming and crying and her hair everywhere he went?
I don't think any of us have a clue and bet.
By the way,
there was nothing like that before him.
There had been some stars,
there had been movie stars,
there had been a bunch of different things.
But when did Elvis really crack?
Was it the fifties or the sixties fifties needles were enormous.
No doubt about it.
And beetles are amazing.
I mean,
some of my favorite songs are Beatles songs,
especially post psychedelic.
So it's not discounting the Beatles,
but Elvis was in a different level even than the Beatles.
The Jesus figure.
It was like the Beatles were a fucking incredible and John Lennon had a lot of
Jesus figure going on with him too and that,
you know,
they were this amazing band,
but there was something about the Elvis,
you know what I mean?
This one mother fucker that would just go on stage and they had a censor his
hips,
they didn't want him to move in like he was fucking on stage.
Women are fainting everywhere.
Crazy.
A lot of
him has to do with the medium that he was experienced and being television first
blast of it,
first blast of TV.
This is the first time that the whole nation is fixated on one point,
you know,
of entertainment and just that,
the new medium I think is really contributed a lot to his importance because his
music was great.
There's no doubt about that for the time.
I mean it was an innovative and incredible,
but it was also the medium
of the television that was innovative in crouch end.
Incredible.
And drove a lot of nothing that ever been looked at before.
They didn't know how to deal with TV and the figures they saw on the television
where like in their living rooms and uh,
you know,
these are people who barely had electricity now going through the houses and now
all of a sudden they've got,
that is amazing to think about.
The distance between 1950 and 1900 and when was electricity really commonplace
in the United States?
218 was Tesla's big thing where he lit up.
This whole area was like super futuristic.
But I think it was one of his demonstrations of the benefits of AC DC current is
instead of direct current,
and he lit up this enormous area with electricity and freaked everybody the fuck
out.
But,
but the distance between that and Elvis is not that far man.
It's like the distance between,
I mean,
what is it,
what it was the years was at 50 years.
50 years.
Well if even 65 yeah,
70 so it's really like the distance between us and them.
I'll say an Elvis.
So if you really think about it,
the dissonance between Austin,
Elvis and the distance between Elvis and electricity are pretty similar.
That's fucking crazy.
Cause Elvis,
even though,
I mean it seems like so long ago,
it's memorable.
I can remember when Elvis was alive.
I'm 43 years old.
When I was a kid,
Elvis was alive.
I think Elvis died on my sister's birthday.
I think that's one of the reasons why.
Like what year did he die on August 18th I have one here
in the 70s yeah,
in the 1970 [inaudible] yeah.
Why don't you Google that shit son?
That's the the,
we've got a new phrase.
Google that shit son.
That's why I say that all day long because we get any,
you know,
I mean you get in these conversations where,
when did he die?
I dunno,
go Google that shit son.
It's so simple.
There's no reason to ever guests anymore.
It's incredible what a time we live in.
But that's our medium.
That's the Internet.
And you know,
our celebrities today are internet celebrities in many cases and reality.
I think that's part of why reality television became so popular is because the
Internet allowed us to think in that way of theirs.
We're connected all of the sudden,
too many realities around the entire world and you can access anybody's
consciousness now and no matter where they are.
And that's why these Middle Eastern countries shut the fucking Internet off.
First thing,
when the shit hits the fan,
when things get ugly,
the first thing they do is they don't want anybody looking in.
They don't want anybody from the United States looking in.
They don't want anybody from Egypt throwing out pictures.
They're going to try to minimize as much video footage and I mean you remember
that one?
There was an uprising and Thailand and a,
there was a famous video online of this,
these rebels,
these people that are fighting against the current regime.
And one guy's fucking head explodes right in front of everybody.
They just took him out with a sniper and he drops the ground and his brains and
blood
are just splattered all over the US.
It's so fucking surreal,
man.
It's so surreal.
And you know,
when,
when shit like that happens now they're just immediately yanking internet.
They're just,
they're trying to do that.
Everybody know the influence is greater than their political influence.
So they also know that it's been successful.
They know that,
you know,
now that they got rid of Mubarak and they move,
mark is being brought up on charges through,
that's fucking crazy.
Mubarak was running,
Egypt was our ally for 30 years.
Protecting the borders into the countries that border them.
That's basically what Egypt was so important to us as an ally for us.
And they're going to run him up on charges on the people that die during the
rebellion.
They're saying that,
you know,
soldiers were murdering people and they're going to see,
I mean this is like some crazy dark shit.
This is an amazing time.
Well,
these are all new things that haven't happened before,
you know,
at least in our time.
And I also think it's easy to get distracted by the novelty of the Internet and
these new forms of,
uh,
communication that come along with it.
But you know,
I,
I think sometimes it's a case that now we can just see more of it and we're
aware of more things more so than,
you know,
what we were talking about with cliff and how technology and the Internet is
like driving people into new areas.
I think that's,
you know,
mainly with porn right now and other areas.
I think a lot of it has always been going on,
Middle Eastern dictators being toppled.
Uh,
and then I don't think we're talking about all these different guys and they
were around for a long time.
We're talking about mole market.
D'Offay remember him?
Did I remember when I was in high school?
Okay.
So,
and then what Saddam Hussein,
you know,
these kinds of around for a long fucking time.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know if necessarily they would have been toppled without,
I mean obviously Hussein would've,
but I mean these,
these ones where their internal revolts,
I don't know if they would have existed without the Internet.
I don't think it was moving that ahead.
I want no way to organize it without getting killed.
Right.
So you'd have to go out in public and,
you know,
say you're going to do it and put up fliers and then meet somewhere and then
they would kill you.
You know,
now you can do it from your cell phone.
You could put Twitter updates,
you know,
this,
this is what's going on.
We cut the power off to the castle,
you know,
like that kind of shit.
They can set up a dancing flash mob and the fucking it,
you know,
uh,
grand central station and at noon,
I'm 20 minutes' notice.
You know,
they could probably get together and fucking pile up some guns and go kill some
mother fucking dictators.
You know,
if you get enough people to respond,
uh,
I'm sure you can mobilize via,
there's something faster than anywhere else.
There's something beautiful about those flash moms.
I love that shit.
It's beautiful.
There's,
there's a,
there's a new TV show that's based around flash mobbing now really where you
have to flash mob or something like that.
Dude,
it's so ridiculous that you can,
you can do that.
You ever see that?
The def photo of a um,
Elvis right there.
Isn't that weird and a funeral photos.
W pretty creepy.
So grainy cameras sucked
back then.
That was like an old school cell phone.
Camera picture.
Yeah.
August 16th by the way,
1977 was the death of the funeral.
Wow.
Is that your sister's birthday?
Did you say August 16th August 16th I was wrong about my sister's birthday.
I thought it was the 18th is the 16th that's fine.
You're close though.
I know it's around my birthday.
It's in the area.
I'm terrible with birthdays because if it's just those little kiddos up,
they were so stupid like,
listen,
dummy,
you'd died once.
Are you?
You were born rather once you're born in 1970 let it go.
What does this,
you know it's my birthday.
No,
it's not your birthday.
no.
It's the day that you were born,
but it's 40 years later.
He needed to let that shit go.
I think the more excited you get about your birthday,
it's most likely that the rest of your life is that much less exciting
exponentially.
I used to get pissed off at is uh,
like if I was dating a girl and I didn't know or remember her birthday,
if she would get mad at me and I'd be like,
what are you doing?
You're,
you're,
you're mad at me.
Cause I don't remember the date it was important to you.
You'd remember my birthday.
That's what,
listen,
I'm nice you every day.
I don't need to remember a special day.
And by the way,
you don't need,
didn't remember my birthday either.
Deal.
We don't have to have a special fucking day where you're nice to people.
I want to be nice to you every time I see you.
I like you.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm going to treat you well.
I don't,
I don't want you angry at me because I don't,
don't remember some stupid fucking day gift though.
Well that those people,
those people that get upset by it and they'll,
they'll say it's not,
I would way rather give somebody something when they don't expect it.
Give somebody something.
Cause I was thinking about them.
I saw this and I thought about you.
If that to me is way nicer and way more special that someone gives you something
on some obligation day.
I'm with that.
You know what I'm saying?
Let it go bitches.
Look at the Statue of Liberty's face it.
A lot of people think that the statue of liberty spaces Elvis Presley.
Um,
if you compare the two,
if you Google statue of liberty and Elvis photos,
and there's a funny comparison,
but didn't the statue of liberty come away before Elvis?
I'm nine.
11 theories that fucking makes your head hurt.
Wait a minute.
What's,
that was the trick and that's why people liked Elvis because he,
they,
he reminded them of the Statue of Liberty and America at the time.
I did a,
an interview today with our radio in Philly.
Real cool guy and fun conversation.
But one of the things that came up were I was laughing about the um,
um,
we're,
we're talking about conspiracy theories that you like.
If you're a person who's a pot,
small girl,
like an avid pot smoker,
you know,
it's probably best not to have conspiracy theories.
That's the first thing that people think,
oh,
he smoked weed and he's in a conspiracy theories how original you can write your
off with that first sentence right away right away.
And you know,
we were talking about that like,
yeah,
if somebody has some sort of conspiracy theory to go along with Jim and Randy,
that's what it was,
classic rock Pittsburgh.
It's important to at least understand them because
you know,
the,
the world needs detectives looking into shit like that could blatantly be false.
You know?
I agree.
There's some value in that,
but I think you'll never find an answer.
Uh,
and part of it,
I guess is because of that,
that there's,
yeah,
there's some things that though that are,
you know,
the,
the idea of conspiracy there,
I hate the phrase conspiracy theorist because it's one of those phrases like,
oh,
it's like someone calling you a misogynist.
Oh,
now there's something you have to defend that's ridiculous.
Like,
well,
who's to decide whether or not someone hates all women?
Just because they run into a few cons in their life.
It doesn't mean they hate all women.
You know how Brian Post saying is going to be here on Monday?
Uh,
he said it best ones.
He said,
this woman said,
you know,
I think he,
we used to go.
So I was in the middle of the argument is with this woman.
She goes,
I think you hate women.
He goes,
that's funny because everyone was ever said that to me.
I hate,
I think it's true.
That's the best way of looking at that and every,
every rose generalization,
but everyone I think is a con.
It's probably in some way a cunt
as well.
In some ways.
We're all capable of consciousness.
I know.
I'm capable of it.
I watched 2011,
28,
2011.
That's funny.
Shit.
Yeah.
Um,
it's like,
man,
I think we're all going to be better off if there weren't words like this that
are so fucking super hyper charged.
I don't think we need to let new words in.
I think,
you know,
like people that are start screaming that all of a sudden a midget is just like
saying nigger.
Then I'll come on.
What do we do our,
yeah,
exactly.
And why does everything have to be,
you know,
just like,
it's just like saying nigger,
every fucking word is like,
just like saying Nigger,
you know midget is just like saying nigger faggot is just like saying nigger.
Like I have heard so many versions of that cunt.
It's just like saying nigger.
No it wasn't.
You know why there's nobody on the nigger equivalent to bitches.
Exactly.
And you know what,
it's,
it's a different thing.
You know,
like everybody wants to say it's like nigger because nigger is the most
offensive thing.
It's a dehumanizing thing.
They just keep going and going,
no,
this is the most you can had things you can't add things to.
The banned list
tells you so much about a person by how much power they ascribed to irrelevancy.
You know,
how much importance did that word have over them?
What did they let that word due to them?
How weak are they in retrospect for that?
For a simple word,
it used in a particular way wielding that much power over you and and your,
your happiness
name.
It's a game because we all know intent and intent is what's important.
And a lot of times when you write something,
intent is lost,
you know,
but when you,
when you,
you,
you describe it and talk about it,
and this is my intent,
you know,
that's supposed to be what's important,
not super charged words,
you know,
supercharged words are so fucking dangerous.
The idea that you can literally start a,
I mean,
you
could walk into a room full of black people and just had no one in particular
say the word nigger over and over again.
And nine times out of 10 someone's going to beat the fuck out of you.
Especially if they look like,
if it looks like you can,
you know,
if you walk in there and you look like fucking Bill Goldberg the wrestler and
maybe you might get off a few niggers and everybody might move around you and
the argument they give and not,
not that group of people specifically for beating you up,
but it's that you're being insensitive to their feelings basically.
And,
and,
uh,
the,
the way that they feel about that word carries such impact upon them that you
have to be conscious of how uh,
that word affects them.
And,
and to some extent I agree that that's why we're polite to each other at a
certain level.
But I think you're also a comic and part of what you do it is,
is it involves giving power and intent to words and kind of shaping a words into
a particular meaning.
And you don't have to be sensitive all the time to every person in the audience
and what they are going to have on their,
you can't shoulders,
you can't or you're not going to get out.
One point of view.
We won't,
some points of view are offensive to other people.
It doesn't mean they're wrong.
It just means they're offensive to your ideals.
You know,
how you're looking at it.
But also you go to an environment a lot where people aren't going to be
offended,
typically saw.
I'm always do.
If you go to a comedy show,
I always let you know,
see a couple people walk out different points of your activity map,
the uptight,
uh,
crazy Christians,
you know,
often get very sensitive about that.
But you know that,
that's part of it too.
I think sometimes you'll get criticized for using a word like conti because
someone who is is not aware of how you use words for your,
your standup act.
Like I'm sure these Maggie centres moving,
using him for my standup act that's using them in regular life.
Right.
All my friends will say Kentucky,
like it's no big deal.
But some people you know will tell you that country is just like nigger.
Well,
they use it to each other.
If I think your friends probably do call each other containers and stuff,
you know,
my friends do.
It's like a funny word.
That's right.
But to some people it's not that at all.
And really the effectiveness is a word of a word is always based on how other
people interpret it.
So clearly I have a degenerate group of friends.
To me it's like a normal word,
but to some people it's like highly charged and offensive.
And I don't mean it that way,
whatever way it's hitting them.
I do apologize for that because I didn't mean it that way.
I didn't mean to hurt people's feelings.
I thought I didn't mean it like,
like I didn't mean like you hear it,
you're like,
oh,
he said that like to me Cunty is like,
one of the things I love about England as you go to England and the other one's
a con.
I use it all the time of just comes flying eyes.
It's fucking cut.
Oh yeah,
this guy's a fucking cut.
Look at it.
It's like good cut fucking bloke.
And this guy was tweeting me and he said,
uh,
in Ireland,
um,
girls say she's be Cunty,
they call each other.
She may kind of
like a sex and the city type thing.
Come on.
How beautiful does that sound?
She's me country.
I'll tell you what,
content is a beautiful word.
If it's used properly and the right context,
like you fucking cunt,
how were they?
Can Be behind that word is amazing.
Dave Foley said it best.
He said,
my ex wife is a fucking con.
He was talking about how horrible his struggle has been,
is financial struggle where he can't even go to Canada to see his kids or he'll
go to jail.
Yeah.
I saw that.
Owe so much money,
three times more than he makes it a month.
He owes.
It's like complete nonsense and craziness.
And when he said,
my wife has a cunt,
like the words resonate.
Yeah.
That was,
there was the reason.
That was the time to use it.
That was the absolute time to use it.
Yeah.
Do you think they would ever be able to make new bad words?
Like,
no.
You don't think it's possible?
No.
But you know the,
the real problem is that it,
the real issue with,
with,
you know,
any,
any sort of bad word like that,
like,
especially like the word nigger with the real issue to me is the impact that it
has on the psychology of a young person,
you know,
and even a girl,
you know what I mean?
Look,
if you tell some little young girl that she's a cunt,
like,
Whoa,
you know,
it's the word is so hyper charged,
it would crush her.
You know what I'm saying?
And if you could tell some boy something,
just a little black boy that he's a nigger,
man,
that's a horrible thing to do to the de-humanize.
Some really insecure and vulnerable child with some definition.
That's sub human.
You know?
That's,
that's where the real issue lives.
It's like with intent.
But I've always wondered about this.
Do you think that bad words need to exist as a,
a natural function of language to represent places where you won't go to
represent places where you know that maybe there should be a word like nigger,
so that when one of your,
your people that you hang out with goes,
yeah,
you know what the problem is?
They're letting niggers vote.
You need to know that this guy is so fucking dumb.
He actually thinks this way.
And we'll say this in that context and any that that a,
that word,
which is so offensive in that context,
you need to know that that guy's capable of that so you can go,
okay,
I'm glad that word exists because of that word didn't exist.
I wouldn't know how fucking stupid you are.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I think that's totally what words are 40 to kind of showed the other person's
mentality or thoughts and 10 that's why intense.
It's like you're supposed to be able to infer it in the context of the
conversation,
you know?
And it's very difficult when people write things down.
You know,
I've seen so many flame wars on the Internet that can totally be avoided.
It's just that someone will write something and kind of a weird way and another
one person,
we'll just make an interpretation of it and in a defensive way and then all of a
sudden it becomes insults and you know it escalates and it gets fucking crazy.
What I like about that whole dynamic though is is what you see now are all these
Internet memes popping up and people and people trying to hide a massive amount
of intent behind a few dopey words that pretty much when use that,
and that means
like you as a human being are prone to getting bought her about insignificant,
inconsequential areas.
But all they say is two words,
six letters you mad question mark.
And so now it's getting harder to understand intent behind people's words
because they're not using broad terminology.
I'm a fan of those photos with little sayings though.
Big Fat cat I love.
Yeah,
cat sayings and the all the ones they've done with Obama,
you know,
those are awesome.
Those are fucking funny man.
Ar,
those are funny.
That's one of the most beautiful things about the internet is we have such a
wide variety of comedy,
you know,
from people that would have never entered into the comedy business.
They just made some sort of a,
an animated Gif file on their own because they know how to fuck with computers
and it's Arnold Schwarzenegger's head on a dog.
That's fucking another dog with his maids face on it and he's fucking her.
And then he throws up after he's done fucking her and then the dog starts eating
the throw up.
And so Arnold doing it in this animated Gif file,
it's fucking hilarious.
And you know,
it's probably some just some dude,
you know,
he's got a job working with computers or maybe he's just at home fucking around
with some program and he slaps it together.
You would have never seen that 20 years.
People don't get the voice,
you know,
to date breast themselves artistically know.
I mean all these internet photos and all these different things.
I mean,
and it's so funny how many different people think up the same thing.
And I don't necessarily even think that it's,
a lot of it is stealing.
I think there's just a lot of parallel thinking.
There's a lot of things,
ideas that were born with as part of our DNA.
There are a,
the way our brains are wired is such that it causes certain thought patterns to
be shared.
And you know that that's how we're wired,
where we share thoughts and ideas that sometimes pop up and very weird and
disturbing ways.
I got to be honest sometimes I enjoy watching a very clever troll take place.
Trolls are fascinating man.
Sometimes they ain't know that shit out of me,
especially when someone's trying to troll me and my bitch stop.
But I do enjoy watching people get roped into some ridiculous argument.
I think they're important.
That's a regional person clearly doesn't mean it is important to see who's in on
it,
who can see who is wise enough to see that they're just expressing the polar
opposite of your own ideas and then someone will inevitably come along with that
photo of the black guy with his finger and says,
y'all niggas be posted in a troll through it.
Okay,
that's inevitable.
He pops up in every,
every good solid troll thread.
Your message board is great though.
Weird place,
man.
I'll tell you,
I actually a,
I think there's a lot more bullshit posted there these days,
but I think some of the people there are terrific and there are some really
sharp mother fuckers that post there regularly.
It's just harder now to,
the numbers are saying to you now,
four and a half million posts on that thing.
When did you start crazy?
When you start the messenger,
it go God damn September,
I think.
How weird is it by the way that you talked about
Swartz and Agar and your dream last week?
And then the next day after saying it,
uh,
all those photos of Arnold Schwarzenegger in naked popped up and those were from
like,
uh,
several years ago,
but they just got leaked out the following day.
That's so ridiculous.
It's so crazy because my dream was I've been taking these nootropics where we're
coming out with this whole line of I'm losing volume again,
dude.
The fuck is going on.
Did you touch that?
I might have to anything Mito.
Did you shut the volume loss son?
Get your fucking,
my foot did didn't
dirty feet off the controllers,
man.
How's that?
Um,
that's cool.
So,
um,
I've been taking,
so that we're coming out with these nootropics and we're,
we're fucking around with the different formulas of it.
And the first initial forming of the crips came up with is really powerful.
It's nuts,
but it's a read the future,
I guess,
and your dreams.
That's one of the side effects.
It was different in my dream and where it took place was different.
And what took place in some fantasy place where it was like,
in my mind,
it was my parents' house.
What's really strange is that I have so much recall of this dream,
which is very rare for me.
I usually don't have this much dream recall,
but this one is very crystal clear.
He was in this House that was my parents' house,
but it wasn't,
and it was on,
my parents lived on the water in Florida and uh,
this was supposedly their house,
but it wasn't their house.
It was just something different.
It was representing their house.
And so I'm hanging out there with them and Arnold Schwarzenegger is walking
around just owning it,
you know,
owning that he's a freak.
And he said,
well,
he was much more muscular.
He looked like the Arnold Schwarzenegger of like,
you know,
like the photos that where he got,
where he got caught.
That was in,
those are the photos where he's naked.
They were released.
That was from like 2000 and 1000 right.
That's what he looked like in my dream.
Wow.
It doesn't look like the Arnold up today.
He looked like the Arnold of like a 50 year old in shape guy.
That's what he looked like.
But owning the fact that he was a freak and he was walking around in his little
tidy little,
you know,
little banana Hammock,
Jammy fucking underwear type things and his balls were so big that he had um,
tucked up behind his asshole and pulled out through the back band.
This is your dream.
Since my band,
the storage gas,
please do.
But anyway,
so this ridiculous fucking dream that I have of Arnold sports and constantly
pulling his dick out,
like washing himself and pulling his pants down and having a need to wash
himself like in front of everybody.
Like it was like preposterous.
Like,
why is this guy was like,
I was thinking,
is this a European thing?
And they,
until like a pulling their pants out of Washington are assholes.
Whether,
you know,
swimming is after his scandal,
uh,
was that all of it was after the scandal.
And so,
um,
so I had this dream and then like two days later these fucking photos came out
and you got those photos.
It's ridiculous,
man.
I mean,
it almost,
the only thing that looks different between him of these photos and him of him,
of my dream is that his hair was longer in my dream.
His hair was like this,
this one young Arnold with the long wavy 1970s hair,
when he was the rock,
that shit,
it wasn't like high and tight.
Like he has it now.
I thought it was just fucking scary.
Like how,
how just the following day I went on Tmz and saw that I was like,
Whoa,
this is just weird upon what would Tyler Durden do?
He had it.
He's our buddy.
He,
uh,
but um,
yeah,
it was very strange that these photos came out.
I mean,
it was basically what I dreamed of.
Just different,
that's really surreal when that happens.
Do you think that's like just synchronicity and uh,
there's some kind of meaningful collective focus on this or it could be that
motherfuckers a free and just pulling his ass out everywhere.
You just had a fucking dream of Colombo Arnold One and two together.
Boy might be the kind of dude to pull his dick out every now and again.
I think he probably,
he's so fucking crazy.
He's over the top crazy.
This is him pulls his pants down.
He's like,
where's my bowls?
Bowls?
The
dead two balls.
And that's exactly what he looked like in my dream.
And it was like muscular still,
but like 50.
But his hair was like following along and he was strutting around like a peacock
and diving in the water and so comfortable.
And I remember thinking,
I gotta get every woman I know fuck out of here.
He's got my fuck my mom.
Like I was thinking,
this is my mom's house aren't swatch.
Let's work.
This guy's a Predator towards Nigga might just pull his dick out in front of my
mom and I might walk in on him and my mom bagging,
nothing your mom could do about it.
She might not be able to handle it.
The fame of Arnold and Arnold Dick and she made me think she could tell my dad
and he would understand that it was just,
it was Arnold.
I mean,
I didn't even mean anything.
You analyze your own dream.
This is getting deep.
I don't know mean it is strange though that two days later this fucking
photograph came out.
That's a Arnold's,
but a crack right there that's,
we're not going to see in that picture.
But I'm looking at it from right here.
That's so strange how clear it is on your,
uh,
on your,
your video but not here.
Looking right at it.
It looks,
it's doing the old pixel thing where from afar it looks normal,
but like,
you know,
close up.
See it's kind of like this painting right here.
So you flipped his asshole.
That's his asshole.
That's why the gap from under it between his ass crack right there and his
balls.
I think the dark area might be his balls.
If you were Richard Hoagland and you are analyzing those arguments on Mars,
I will find and you're like,
Whoa,
whoa,
homeboy back the fuck up.
That's a bird.
That's rock and it's tiered.
Yeah.
This is a burden.
If you notice,
if you draw a line between this rock and that rock,
you're like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
You just making shit up.
You're deciding where to measure and you're,
you're saying,
well,
this matches this setup in Egypt,
but fuck it does.
It doesn't look anything like,
he just reminds me of how unsophisticated we are when it comes to space travel
because of the ideas that we're still giving credence to.
We've got people who believe what he's saying about Mars and all that.
I just,
I think it's a real fucking shame that we can't get there with cameras and
fucking,
it is a chilly really explore that place,
but I do think that there is something to a few of those structures.
There are some of those high resolution photographs.
None of the face I look at the face,
that's not interesting to me.
That looks like it could be shadows.
Right.
Is Interesting to me is the base of the face.
The base of the face looks pretty symmetrical.
Not completely but enough to the,
you might think,
wow,
what does,
what is that?
What is that?
And there's a few of these other ones that are like five of start,
five sided pyramids and you,
you look at those and go,
wow,
they're really does look like it might be at one point in time,
thousands of years ago,
it could have been some sort of a structure,
but or not.
It could have easily not been anything.
When you look at that thing,
I mean it looks like I'm just a mountain to me,
man,
I look at this,
this is the one that freaked everybody out,
but they've determined that when they,
when they took the photographs,
the the,
the high resolution photographs so much closer when they've determined it's
just,
this is just a trick of lighting.
It's really that simple.
What's more interesting is the outside of the,
of the face on Mars,
but some of the pyramids are kind of trippy but not trippy enough where you
would go.
You definitely know that that is a pyramid and that someone built that,
you know,
50 million years ago.
I think lost civilization is very interesting as a concept.
And I like,
I like looking for it.
I think there's nothing definitive on Mars.
Well you know that thing that they found in Turkey recently,
they had very sophisticated temple in Turkey cut.
It was back when and it really re it fucks up the whole dating for the whole
hunter and gatherer versus a settlement because this is 9,600 BC.
They thought that people didn't even have agriculture back then.
And yet here's this amazingly sophisticated temple with uh,
you know all these stone carvings of different animals and birds and shit.
It's called the go Beckley Eco Beck look up like a new site in Turkey predates
civilization.
So,
and this is,
this shit is all 9,600 BC and it these big stone columns.
These are just hunter gatherers back then.
So everybody's freaking out.
They're like,
how did hunter gatherers stop and build this and not just build it?
But apparently they buried at all because it was really well preserved and
they're,
they're freaking out about that.
They're saying,
well,
this is something that wasn't even like weathered for thousands of years.
There's some,
it's so well preserved that had been covered.
So it's just really rare opportunity for these archeologists to study this
really totally unknown little section of the world.
It'll tech,
they have technology now that they can find those kinds of things.
But yeah,
I mean I,
and you always want to finding a bunch of new pyramids because of that.
They jumped,
they found a bunch of new burial sites,
a bunch of new pyramids,
all with satellite technology.
I was going to say,
I,
I really do believe that there's been many iterations of wireless technology
used in different forms throughout the history.
Yeah,
I do because one,
it's impermanent.
I,
I think that the nature of it,
other than satellites,
I mean there's,
we would probably know if there were satellites floating around up in space,
but maybe not.
But I think that it's likely that other tech,
um,
civilizations,
ancient civilizations have had forms of wireless technology that don't last.
Because if you think about how our wireless technology is set up with antennas
and the way that you have to use radio waves and you know,
point them,
uh,
it,
they're not prone to lasting under,
you know,
disaster.
So I mean,
you know,
ancient Egyptians in the way that they used their pyramids could have well been
associated with some sort of wireless,
a antenna and some sort of,
I'm not saying it's likely,
I'm saying that I'm open to the idea of game center right there.
The idea that,
yeah.
Then that school,
Becky,
what did you,
what do they call it?
How they're described this place?
What is it called?
The heroin,
let me go back to the actual crazy name.
Cool.
9,600 BC man.
Yeah,
it's really nuts.
Go Becky [inaudible] or something like that.
How do they actually creation at the six day creation?
A six planets are kind of temple.
How do you say this name?
Quebec.
Quebec Lee Tepi.
Is that how you said go back to the tap and go back to lead happy either way.
Incredible discovery.
Do you think that that um,
like you one of those people that believes that there's been a series of
cataclysmic disasters and people have rebounded so they reach great heights?
I think it's likely that great civilizations emerge and then dissipate.
And you know,
we've,
we've seen that we just don't have much historical evidence of anything really.
If you think about it,
it's only because of our technology and our books even that we're able to,
to have a semblance of what occurred throughout time.
So,
and we've only been keeping records for so long and so that's why,
you know,
the pyramids are interesting and the hieroglyphs and the uh,
Dead Sea scrolls were really interesting and,
and those kind of historical records are very important.
And I don't know that we keep important historical records if this world and its
civilization is wiped out or eliminated.
The real thing is when everything goes digital,
right?
Because then no hard copies of it that we can take with us places.
And then essentially all information from a certain period of time forward gets
lost and he sort of cataclysmic.
Right.
And that's where I think a lot of,
uh,
archetypal a religious imagery emerges from are those times where we can't
really explain what happened and we don't remember.
There's no record.
So we have to fill because it's our inclination to look back,
uh,
to fill with myth and mythology is what we do when we don't know what else to do
or how to explain something.
Yeah.
And you know,
the John Anthony West guy is a,
he's a,
the egyptologist that's spent so much time trying to move the date of the
Egyptian history back far,
far,
far the past whether he
wants to predate them than before 10,000,
500 BC.
He thinks that it's been like a 34,000 year old history and that they can show
it in hieroglyphs.
But they always say to him like,
where's the evidence?
Where's the evidence of this besides the,
uh,
water erosion on the Sphinx.
And besides all the hieroglyphs that detailed these pharaohs going back way,
way far in the past,
they look at those pharaohs from like 34,000 years ago and they say,
well that's just fiction.
It's just folklore and a certain point in time it became fact.
But when you,
it's really fun to pass.
It's folklore and uh,
but the real question is what would be left of us like this room.
Okay.
With all these televisions and all this electronics and shit,
if we died,
if there was a nuclear blast and North America was wiped out,
how long would this shit last?
Oh Shit would be gone in a few thousand years.
Two or 3000 years.
Everything that's in that metal box,
we'll have been swallowed up by the [inaudible].
Yeah.
The things that last are like oil based things like,
you know,
they always talk about landfills in the kind of thing that will fill a landfill
for thousands of years and it's like your plastic bags and things that are made
of oil or the thing the substance they originate from is,
you know,
a,
a natural substance.
Those are the kinds of things that stick around and that's what remains on this
planet.
It's a,
I don't know,
stone stone,
the way to really mark angel labs.
I mean everything that we know that's really,
really,
really old that people make.
We know because it was,
it was made out of stone.
I don't know if anything else would be around,
you know,
I think that most would and all these things would rot out and water overtakes
this was water can overtake that.
Like those,
those um,
sunk in,
uh,
structures outside of Japan that there've been arguing back and forth or whether
or not their natural man,
I,
I've looked at those,
there are cut pieces of fucking slabs that are perfectly cut,
stacked one right next to each other.
And if you're looking at some of the aspects of it,
you go,
well,
I guess it could be some really strange natural phenomenon.
It is possible,
but not when you get to these slabs,
there's these two slabs that are like these monoliths that are so clearly cut
and quarried and they're stacked right next to each other.
And I look at that and I go,
okay,
well there's so many made this,
this is bullshit.
So,
and they know that this part of Japan had been underwater as recently as like
10,000 years ago.
So like it up until rather recently.
It's like 10,000 years ago.
So this is like some fucking incredibly old shit somebody made and it just got
swallowed up by the ocean and you can still see it.
And if you know that that's where the water was and you know that the land had,
you know,
water had covered over that area for the last,
x thousand years,
then you know,
how old this shit is roughly,
you know,
and,
but they're not willing to look at it that way.
There they,
it's so preposterous to them that they're,
they're,
they,
they look at it and say it's a natural formation.
But on the other hand,
Dell embrace climate change right now as if we're in danger of being submerged
around the edges.
And,
uh,
I think it's just part of the cycle of this planet.
We go through periods where we freeze and melt.
And I don't know how much man
contributes to climate change.
I think,
I know it happens though.
And I know that things,
you know,
uh,
disasters like the tsunamis we've been seeing will overtake land and wash away
whatever's there and you know,
throughout thousands of years there's really no telling what man,
where man has come from.
I think that's why it's so fascinating to think about most people,
uh,
that are religious.
Uh,
it gives them their answers.
You know,
it says this is where we came from.
It was fucking magic.
And that's where,
you know,
so we're going to find answers to that.
I think people that are skeptical and curious individuals who,
uh,
will look back and wonder,
you know,
we'll talk about shit like this and kind of say what could have been,
and it's a volatile situation.
The Earth's position is,
it moves,
you know,
the earth's position around the sun in new,
we know,
we,
we were,
we're spinning around this thing and we're spinning on this axis and you know,
the,
the climate changes,
sometimes things get radically different.
North America 10,000 years ago was covered under a mile of ice.
You half of North America was covered by ice.
Yup.
A mile high.
Man,
this is just 10,000 years ago.
We'll,
we'll,
we're pretty sure 10,000 years ago we didn't have global warming because of
carbon dioxide made my engines.
What I mean it's like I think I,
and I wonder too,
when I see like ancient civilizations like Egypt,
I wonder if we're looking at society one way because we have this petrochemical
based society,
this,
you know,
we have this gasoline and oil and plastic based society that we use it.
It's such an important resource to us.
What if there was a society that figured out some other way,
right?
They were based around different natural resources or they figured out some
other way of to manipulate matter.
I mean there's a lot of questions as to how the pyramids were construction.
If they stack those stones where they got them,
the ones that were cut from there was some of them,
the quote from a quarry there was hundreds of miles away.
They don't know exactly how they transported those things,
those massive,
huge fucking stones and buy.
There's only that,
there's not that many people on the planet back then.
Supposedly there's only supposed to be like 2 million people on the whole planet
back then.
And how do they do that?
I mean there's,
there's a lot of possible explanations,
but there is not any evidence of how that was done.
That's,
that's beyond a reasonable doubt to still wonder.
And you know,
I,
I just argue with that.
It's amazing.
People will argue with that,
but that's not interesting.
No,
no,
no.
We've get figured it out.
You're wrong.
It's like they take this religious position.
It is like,
almost like you're questioning God,
you know,
when you say,
I don't think we do know how the fuck they built the pyramids.
And you know,
there's also significant evidence that was,
that they were made out of concrete and they would did it.
His word Horn.
Yeah.
These stones.
The significant evidence.
I agree.
As far as the composition of the stones.
I mean I've seen it argued it's a,
it's a,
it's a fascinating point of view.
And if that was true,
well then want to make it considerably easier to,
to make these things cause you would just sort of cast these stones as you moved
along,
but that still doesn't make up for the margin of error.
The margin of error there were so spectacular would their construction methods
that there was,
it was a perfect thing all the way to the top of 2 million,
300,000 stones.
I mean that's an amazing thing.
I wonder what kind of calculations they were capable of back then.
You know,
when that library of Alexandria burned down,
we lost so much information about how Egypt figured things out and what their
history was and how they put it all together.
But the stuff that they did is so amazing and beyond comprehension for someone
who lived literally 5,000 plus years ago,
they were measuring their,
their distance to the stars and they were using the universe as a tool to guide
what they were doing.
And there's evidence of this at least.
And I always wonder how much technology did they have and what is our technology
doing to us that could potentially kill us off as you said.
And that's why it doesn't last because we're not around to make it,
you know,
you're talking about sentient machine deciding where the bad guy,
but what,
you know,
what if our simple internet technology and cell phones are killing are going to
ultimately kill us off with the,
the type of a radio wave they're pumping into our bodies and our children and
the genetic effect that these technologies have.
This is brand new and things of the rise in autism and epilepsy and these kinds
of issues I think is directly a,
it's another area that needs to be looked at and discussed.
But no one is doing that in the medical,
the scientific community.
Um,
there aren't many of these studies that,
that seem like they should be important lady radiation studies and let's see,
I mean they're,
they just came out with uh,
evidence and I think the World Health Organization published a report where,
and they agree that cell phone technology is,
uh,
can cause cancer in your brain if you use it on your ear all the time.
It was
Anderson Cooper was talking about it.
It was saying that what you have to do is you have to hold it away from your
ear.
Right.
And I was like,
what are they saying?
Like they were measuring it,
the acceptable amount of radiation that comes off of these headsets.
But they said the way to measure it is it has to be away from you here,
if you use it the way everybody else uses it,
when you put it actually up to your ear,
hold it.
Especially if there's a lot of people talking around your pressure up your ear
frying your brain.
I'm not saying it's going to literally fry your brain.
I just mean there are radio waves that are going into your brain that well the
question is fine.
It's debatable how much of it is healthy or how much of it you can take.
And we carry it in our pocket to right and our sperm is as potentially,
it's definitely receiving the radiation from the phone.
So who knows what that's going to have the effect that that's going to have
maybe nothing,
but maybe you know,
it's very possible.
It's so new.
We just don't know if she'd had rabbit,
but
that was born,
uh,
outside of the blast zone in the,
um,
the uh,
and Japan where the reactors are down a rabbit.
We started wearing a rabbit was born.
That was no ears.
Wow.
A lot of the freak round headed rabbit with no ears.
It's so weird,
man.
It's weird.
It's got a round head.
Nuclear technology
is the most likely suspect to kill all of us in,
in,
in this generation.
And to wipe up out this whole planet even more than you know,
comets and asteroids.
I think,
uh,
it's very possible,
but it's still,
uh,
sugar on this rabbit.
This is this little girl right here is good.
No years.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That's an x man rabbit I'd like to have.
It's going to take over the world and 10 years,
is it after I've put on a black leather suit and he's going to be a,
I'm like a man and he'll be the x men.
He'll be the bad guy.
That nuclear rabbit.
That's great.
Yeah.
The,
the amazing thing is that they allow these people to make these reactors and
they didn't have a multitude of backup plans for this incredible amount of
energy that you're producing and you're trying to contain.
And we use the same technology here in many cases they were talking about
California are a lot of our,
uh,
reactors are rated to withstand a,
you know,
a 6.9 earthquake or a 7.1 earthquake.
Well,
what do you know?
What about an 8.141 or any point to you?
And they're trying to predict the faults that they lie on and what they're
capable of to do that.
So if we'll have the same thing in California,
we have an earthquake like that and the big one is near San Diego,
right on the ocean.
Right on the ocean guys,
there's photos of guys surfing and right behind them you see this nuclear
fucking power plant and it's like what?
That's crazy.
It's amazing.
And
do you know how what crazy bad lands it's going to be between San Diego and
Mexico?
If that reactor black,
that reactor when it goes black and then the guard goes down,
everybody moves out of the border.
There's nobody watching the border.
So Tiawana all of a sudden become San Diego in a flood of humanity.
Reactors melting down.
Yeah.
There's people that are living in San Diego,
especially like in La Jolla and he's fucking fantastic mansions and they are 20
minutes,
half an hour Max away from Tiawana.
What all you have to do is get your fucking car from your mansion and in a half
an hour you can be in one of the scariest cities on the planet.
You know some the tomatoes are coming in.
We've got tomatoes,
our own tomatoes for our salad for lunch.
That's wonderful.
I'm going to shopping.
I'm going to take the poodle.
She's taken the poodle shopping,
walking down the street and 20 minutes away,
people are selling their children.
Oregon's left the right,
Oregon's left and right.
Violence everywhere.
Headless police officer's stacked,
legalize and coat.
Taco stand,
total anarchy.
Well,
they've decriminalized everything.
They've decriminalized every fucking drug.
Good for you.
People don't know if you want to get fucked up.
If you're,
if you're not scared,
if you ain't scared,
homie,
go to Mexico,
go to Mexico.
You just got to find the right gardener.
Find the right dude.
You know,
it was working.
Go to one of those resorts and uh,
the,
the Gardner that looks,
you know,
the gardener,
it looks like the cool guy.
That's still my friend,
my friend.
Um,
yeah.
Know your country has a deep history of mushrooms.
You're your people.
Embrace this.
Yeah.
How was a Gringo like myself?
Get Ahold of such a thing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it's not worth it.
So dangerous.
They just found another bunch of dead people and Poco just giant piles of bodies
down so crazy.
They're just killing each other.
There's way more people have died over there that American troops in Afghanistan
and Iraq,
they said that the death toll from the drug war is somewhere around,
it was somewhere around 28,000.
Now that's like the imagine 28,000 bodies stacked on top of each other.
They would know it's not working anymore.
I mean,
it's not even a drug war.
It's about the war of the,
it's a civil war going on there.
It's about territory and power and money just like every other war.
And we've demonized this because their commerce is drugs and we,
we buy from them and we kind of use their native industry to,
uh,
perpetuate this civil war.
That bomb that you just showed in the background,
the bombing of Hiroshima in the water,
the one that blew up in the water.
This is just showing a collection of tons of different,
uh,
nuclear explosions.
It's just from the beginning.
Did you rewind it?
No.
There's one,
if you can find it where they want,
it doesn't matter.
But they blew up one,
right?
The ocean to the testing and the ocean.
Yeah.
They did a testing and the ocean and it was fucking insane.
The water shot up like a mile into the sky.
It's insane.
It's so beautiful.
So destructive but so incredible and beautiful at the same time as much.
Yeah.
These,
these crazy ass holes looking at this one.
Look at that.
So this isn't this what killing the water for real John Wayne.
Basically this,
no,
not this one.
John Wayne got killed by the one that was in the desert.
Right,
right.
Man,
it's amazing man that we've created something that does that.
And by the way,
we do it way better now.
The new ones are way stronger when they're coming out with new ones.
They were able to contain anti-matter for 16 seconds the other day.
Wow.
I don't know what that means.
No,
but I know that,
you know,
I've heard,
uh,
there's been development there where they're trying to develop an anti matter
weapon.
So if they're trying to develop an anti matter weapon and they been able to
contain matter for 16 seconds,
it's very possible they're eventually going to come up with something.
They can actually harness that shit somehow.
I don't even understand what anti matter is.
It just,
it causes matter to a,
it's not matter.
Yes.
Hates matter.
Matter Hates Mamet.
It causes matters
and it just fucks matter up something that's like a Nigga Kryptonite for matter.
Is that what it is?
I think so.
Basically well anti matter is uh,
a physics term isn't it?
And that's what they're,
their military,
the way we're talking about is how the military is developing it and harnessing
it to basically use it as a weapon and
some point,
I think that's how all things get funded there.
You know,
it has to be,
there has to be some potential for weaponry.
And you like the large Hadron collider in that court glue on plasma.
Incredibly dense,
40 billion tons sugar cube size.
Why would they make something like that?
Cause it would be the most awesome bullet ever.
Did you imagine you shot a bullet and 40 billion tons and that bullet hits your
city.
Can I take care of you buddy?
Hey,
where's that city?
It's not even here anymore.
Why is there a new ocean in its place?
That's just anti matter.
Yeah.
I mean,
could you imagine,
could you imagine if they come up with something that literally knocks off giant
chunks of the earth?
Just like an apple.
It took a,
you know,
someone took a slice out of it.
Pretty much what happens and that why we have moons and,
yeah,
right,
right.
That's the number one theory is earth one in earth too,
but it's,
it's a collision.
That earth was actually hit by something and that it was so fucking big.
Whatever it is,
it hit us.
It broke off a giant chunk and created the moon blocked off forcible.
Yeah.
Very positive.
Walker.
Cow Count wants to play slot machine now.
Yeah,
you cancer are annoying.
They're a little needy.
Like that's annoying to my cats.
Needy as funny.
My cat is not allowed in the room while the podcasts is going on anymore because
she's,
she's rude.
She's,
it's always about her as she meows a lot.
Yeah.
My cat meows a lot.
She wants attention.
She'll sit up on my lap,
just start me out on like right in the mic man.
That shit's rude.
We got this pac man machine in the other room that I got and my cat's gotten to
the point where it loves to,
uh,
chase the ghost on it.
So it's learned how to,
uh,
hit the player one button so it starts the game and it just sits there and
chases the ghost on the PAC man.
And then it's annoying as fuck.
Cause you're just like laying here watching TV and suddenly here don't,
I mean you're an earner.
You need to make your video.
Yeah.
The video though.
So you're the king of cat videos and uh,
he's just too busy.
But you need to do that.
That's something you needed to do.
You need to trick that cat and the doing it for you now because it might be one
of those things you'll,
he does like once every three days and if you're not there when it happens,
how often does he do it?
Every,
every day.
He,
that's his name.
Yeah,
I'll do it.
Set up some,
set up some motion detector camera right on that it just come on your fucking Mr
Johnny I spy.
You know how to do this.
He doesn't like the slot machine though,
cause it can't figure out how to put coins and to start it.
That slot machine hookers on it.
There's a little girls in our underwear there
and then you're a little Hitler cat.
Yeah.
You Man.
Boy you think this fucking shows over folks.
They're like,
we petered out.
I think we hit the end like Brian's cap talk.
That's all it took.
He just pulled his fucking an apocalypse.
Mexico anti matter and he's like,
yeah,
I'm,
all cats are fluffy
video games.
Don't go to Mexico.
I guess.
Whatever.
What are you going to move when the shit hits the fan?
Do you have a spot?
You know,
I'm just going to stay where I am and fucking watch it.
Ride it out.
Ride it out,
man.
Beans.
Yeah,
I just don't think there's anywhere great to go.
I do.
I have a,
yeah,
got to talking to that microphone.
Sorry about that.
Yeah,
I do not like that.
There you go.
Felon all so no,
I mean I don't really have any plans because where are you really going to go to
hang out with the fucking desert?
People are,
you know that know the terrain better than you.
There's going to be Mad Max,
right?
Yeah.
I'll probably the lands between Santa Monica or San Diego and Mexico.
If I had to really slowly,
if shit was going down,
I'd go up into the mountains.
Probably could you have and how crazy it would be if there was something that
was so serious that the border didn't exist anymore and the borders were opened
up and everybody from Tiawana just came running over.
That's the John Lennon Song.
Imagine.
Imagine there was no countries.
Well,
imagine you live in Canada.
That's what I imagined.
I imagined him.
I'll give some moving to Toronto.
I'm going to learn how to shovel snow again.
Canada's one.
Canada is amazing,
but you can't even get into Canada if you have a fucking,
if you put gum under a table,
they won't let you in Canada.
Even your kids have to have passports.
We just went and got my kids,
uh,
two passports because they can't get in without it anymore.
I've got a 18,
19 month old girl and a seven year old boy and they both,
you,
no one can get across the border without a passport.
Wow.
Even babies,
even babies.
Wow.
That's amazing man.
Yup.
Yeah.
Well that's why it's so cool up there.
I mean,
Canada has,
I would say 10 to 20% less douche bags per capita than the United States to us.
Right.
They're very polite.
I mean,
my wife and I,
and they're,
they're just great people.
I mean,
eh,
but there's still this sort of arrogance.
I mean,
they were watching America like,
you know,
you people are fucking crazy.
They're just,
could you imagine being connected to the,
the nuttiest?
It's really like us and Mexico.
Mexico,
look at Mexican,
but no,
because you know,
obviously it's safer than that in most spot America is getting a little more
violent and dangerous.
We were talking yesterday about Detroit and about how nutty it is.
A Detroit has 47% illiteracy rate and that,
you know,
when you're living in a place like that,
it's,
you know,
it's really scary because information doesn't pass along anymore.
Yeah.
And La,
I mean,
50% of our high school kids don't graduate and the Lha 50% 50% crazy,
3% drop out or get a GED,
47% of the kids who go through La Public Unified School district,
uh,
don't graduate.
That's terrifying.
Yeah.
Even high school.
I don't even get out of high school.
Nope.
That makes you feel like you just got to get out.
You got to get up.
Don't get Adam Carolla started on this.
People are starting charter schools and you know,
they're trying to,
if we don't educate our,
our children properly in general,
but I think homeschooling makes a lot of fucking sense nowadays.
I think just just teach your kids yourself on this would be a better idea,
but your kids are socially ill adjusted then.
Yeah.
You know,
it's just the fact,
I've known a lot of homeschool kids in my life and they're just socially awkward
and you know one,
you know,
you don't resent them for it,
but they just have a hard time in groups and paying attention.
It's part of life.
You're supposed to be hanging around with someone your age and you know,
and all figuring shit out together.
You know,
it's,
it's supposed to be,
that's,
that's a part of it all.
The problem is when you have 50% that aren't graduating and the kind of climate
that that creates,
50% of don't give a fuck 50% that are just causing trouble.
50% that are just,
you know,
just eking through life.
Yeah,
it's,
it's tough.
I mean,
but a lot of rich refrigerator,
that noise now it's outside air conditioner and the nailers.
What kind of a fucking studio?
This ghetto,
I'm thinking about moving actually soon.
Are you going to,
you've been here for awhile and then here too.
I'm just,
I,
this time when you move you should probably not tell people where you're moving
to.
Yeah.
I just,
I'm done with not having one bathroom is just awful.
You can't fucking have one bath.
We can't have a studio.
Also people coming to your house so much to Andy.
Dick been showing up in any decks in the kitchen for Andy did.
He got arrested shortly after show.
It's amazing.
I never would have thought then we'll decide happened actually at the
conversation you had,
I saw that podcast and he's like crazy sometimes.
You know,
sometimes I'm sober,
sometimes I'm not.
Sometimes I'm gay,
sometimes I'm straight.
He was like whatever.
I just don't really embrace any particular idea of how I am and what I believe
in sticking to his guns.
I was bullying and we work together really so ridiculous.
He was so out of control and you just had to yell at him like,
don't touch my Dick [inaudible] every day.
Living like,
Oh made everyday living hell cause I would threaten them.
Don't pull your dick out.
Stop it.
I loved it.
You did love that show.
I think it was just funny seeing it was you out of your element for,
for the,
for a weird deal.
You have to manage him.
He's dangerous.
Irrational.
He's nuts.
What are you,
when he started talking about being attracted to me,
I was like,
oh Jesus,
how such?
Yeah,
she knows how to make you uncomfortable though.
I could tell by watching that he was actually more than anyone I've ever seen
and we've known each other for a long time.
I've never seen you as uncomfortable as you were during that change.
How you know he has a thing for you or use to and you're just like [inaudible]
never seen you at a loss.
Also one of the funniest people I've ever worked with,
he's very,
very talented and I almost think that you,
you almost have to be kind of crazy to be that funny because I'm telling you,
we did some scenes together and Andy made me laugh harder than anybody I've ever
worked with ever by far.
There was more scenes with him where I had to stop because I was laughing and I
couldn't go on.
I fucked up the scene there.
I used to happen all the time.
It was so,
he was,
he's really good.
He was a really good,
like comedic actor and I think it's almost like to be that character that he
was,
you almost have to be completely wild in real life.
You know why you keep fucking with the satellite?
I'm talking he needed more up and down,
left,
left.
It's only the headphone Jack something wrong.
I heard that wasn't my faith this now,
you know,
I always think that whenever I see anybody that's brilliant but crazy.
I almost say I think you have to be crazy to be brilliant,
you know?
Yeah.
I think I really do.
He,
the way he was nurtured as a child,
probably doesn't remember it.
He doesn't remember anything before like age eight.
It's kind of like he's a product of his environment.
I mean,
just as much as any of us are close.
That's probably an interesting subject.
Yeah.
I mean,
no one knows what kind of fucking hand you're going to be dealt with born into
this world.
And oftentimes it's a fucking mess.
But it's just,
um,
that's so true.
When I see people and I see fascinating people,
I always wonder how much is nurture?
How much is nature?
You know,
what,
what does it take to create a person like this?
You know,
and it went and talented people,
the most talented comedians that I know are the most out of control.
You know,
like Joey Diaz keeps it together today,
like this taste.
But I've never met a more out of control person in my life.
And I've also never met a funnier person in my life,
you know?
I mean,
he's,
he's the funniest guy I've ever met.
He was,
he's,
he's ridiculous
bar in La the other night and he was just standing on the stage,
you know,
everyone's super baked.
So no one really got the jokes until like three seconds afterwards and he's just
going mad.
It was,
it was a beautiful thing.
And he's like,
this is the fucking wait house.
And he's like losing his mind sweating.
And just hilarious.
But no one was getting it because everyone's so high.
Oh,
it was hilarious.
Super
high crowd is a different animal.
I've only done a few.
I've done a few of those.
Uh,
they used to do medical marijuana shows at the comedy store.
I've done those,
but they weren't nearly as intense as the one I did in Toronto where you're
allowed to smoke in the club.
So the club was filled with bongs.
I mean it was ridiculous.
It was so thick.
It was like doing comedy inside a cloud and I'm not bullshitting.
My throat was killing me the next day because I was essentially just breathing
in pot.
There was no air left in the room.
It was like we were just redistributing each other's pot,
smoke recycled breath everywhere.
Yeah,
it was,
that was,
uh,
that was completely ridiculous.
And it was,
I felt like shit the next day after that,
my throat,
because it was smoky in there.
If you're going to have a fucking look,
I go to a cigar bar cause I'm fucking high roller like that.
I go and I was like,
oh blah.
I would talk about scripts.
This is what everybody does.
The Cigar Bar,
they all sit down with scripts and go over this guy and [inaudible] and he's
going to be
the lead.
The black white girls like them.
But they've got air systems.
Exactly.
That's my point.
While we're smoking these cigars,
it said that the have Havana room and there's,
there's these things that suck air out of the room.
So it's always air conditioned and it's always clean.
So even though you're sitting there with a big fat stokey the air,
you're smoking,
breathing,
it doesn't suck.
That's the way you're supposed to do it.
But these fucking hippies,
they just some more here man with smoker in here.
You didn't even have a window.
You fuck.
It's like what Amsterdam is like.
Everyone's like,
oh,
you got to go to Amsterdam and I've got to go fucking sit in their hash bars and
try it out over there.
I'm like,
why?
So I can sit there and breathe second hand breath from all these fucking growth
forest and people do the bar,
the bud tender,
this place,
real cool guy.
But he's serving water.
You know,
like little cups.
Everyone had a Dixie Cup that was see through and they were pouring water out of
jugs into this cup and everyone's got the exact same cop.
And I was like,
boy,
this would be a great place to roofie somebody.
No,
but if I was
go on on the TV,
Huh?
I don't know.
But it made no sense at all because it seemed like the beverages would be the
most important.
Like you would make so much money from that.
Like you're,
you're,
these people are like totally stoned and totally fucked up on Hash.
They're going to be hungry and thirsty.
If you want these people to stay here and fucking make some money,
sell some $20 ice teas and we'll have to,
I hope
they're listening to this.
Yeah,
well didn't they just say that now you can't have tourists and I'm in Amsterdam.
Amsterdam.
Yeah.
I can't smoke pot.
In September of this year,
they've passed some sort of ordinance.
These things come and go.
They don't always last.
But yeah,
they,
they've basically banned tourists,
locals only,
which is fine.
And I've been there many times and it's kind of,
you go there once you experience it,
that's cool.
But it's just a smokey room where they sell weed.
I think what we have in California here is vastly superior.
We have many better strains.
We have all of the Dutch strains,
all the Nevilles haze in the hybrids that have come from the Netherlands,
white widow and originated there.
We've got all those strange strains and all of Canada and what we've created
here in the states,
and it's clean.
Usually with the exception of this place,
you,
you don't have to breathe other people smoke and you know,
it's,
it's just a better vibe down here,
the medical community.
And I like,
I like this much,
much more.
People in other states don't have any idea how huge it is.
Oh,
it's so huge.
It's something that's kept off the mainstream news for the most part,
but it really has revolutionized the city of La.
Yeah.
I mean it's this,
this is a different fucking city.
There's all a lot more stoners.
There's a lot more and it's easy access,
openly discussed as well.
I mean,
I,
I'd talked about it with my fucking nanny the other day.
I mean,
it's like,
it's okay.
It's how it should be.
You have to be very responsible though with the way you do it here.
And it's,
it's a clean,
a positive experience.
I mean it is for the most part how it's supposed to be and that's what it would
be if it was all legal.
You fucks if it was all legal
and you could buy it anywhere and you know,
just had to have a license to sell it,
just like you have to have licensed to sell liquor.
It would be amazing.
It'd be so much tax money that would be generated from this.
It would,
it would,
it would revolutionize the,
the culture,
the way people interact with each other,
make people so much nicer.
Yup.
But it's happening.
It's happening slowly.
Right?
It is.
I mean,
we're seeing it here where at the very forefront and,
uh,
I would rather,
you know,
come to La for a,
this experience and then go to Amsterdam in any case.
But Colorado has got the same thing.
Yeah.
Colorado right now was just like this Washington,
I guess Jason,
uh,
mute was telling me that they opened up a medical community shops and co-ops,
up in Seattle now
30,
around Seattle.
So progressive.
It's amazing.
They'd be so far behind San Francisco because San Francisco and Oakland,
I mean,
they've had that shit forever now,
you know?
I mean,
they've,
they're,
they're just open as fuck about it up there.
Yup.
Hmm.
What's the problem there is,
there is no problem,
man.
It's just,
it's a disgusting situation where everybody has to deal with the fact that it's
still illegal federally.
It's just so stomach turning.
Yeah.
I mean,
I think the,
the real point of it all is it,
it would be nice to be able to use hemp for things to be nice,
to be able to have long lasting,
durable goods.
Yeah.
But it's amazing how many people
don't even know about that.
What did it makes?
Superior paper,
superior building products.
It's incredibly light,
but amazingly strong doesn't have to grow for 20 years.
Like a tree.
It grows quick and it's,
the fiber is like fucking alien fiber took the most amazing fibers for making
clothes and paper way.
Superior paper were used to paper that just rips real easy papers like way
stronger than cotton paper then rather tree paper.
But all the hemp again now has to be imported from Canada,
has regulated and licensed so stupid.
You can't,
hamp can't even get you high now.
You know,
there's people don't understand it's so it's a cousin of marijuana.
I mean it's,
it's,
you know,
it's related to marijuana but it's not,
doesn't have any THC in it.
They grow that shit just to make clothes out of it and just to make sales and
you know,
they did that forever.
George Washington fucking grow it.
The end definitely was tired of that.
That stoner ramble.
Yeah.
Hey man,
we can make like oil out of it man.
Biodiesel man.
Well we were,
we were talking about uh,
Amsterdam and I'll have to tell you I'll fire,
but uh,
the crazy,
it's cold and there's whores everywhere.
Is that good?
That pretty much sums it up.
And,
and frank was there.
And Holla at your boy.
Um,
tomorrow night I'll be at the Improv and it's true.
He does it in Ontario.
A Braille Braille,
right?
Brian,
thank,
I'm pretty sure it's Breyer.
They improvident Braya for Jody Diaz.
It show,
oh,
that's tomorrow night I'm going to a headline that and then a Thursday night
I'll be at the vogue in Vancouver,
British Columbia.
Thursday the ninth some I'm fucking fired up.
I can't wait to get back up to Vancouver and uh,
that's it.
So we'll be back next week.
I know Brian Post saying is going to be on the podcast on Monday and we'll see
who else we got.
Kokoon so I don't forget flashlights to hate you and have you seen this one?
Don't touch it.
I'll look at it.
Don't smell it.
It smell it.
Either the flashlights sponsor of our podcast and if you go to a Joe rogan.net
and click on the link for the fleshlight and in the code name Brogan,
you get 15% off.
And don't let Brian ever put one in your face or make you touch it.
It's not a nice dude.
I saw one in your bathroom once that had a pube stuck to it,
and it's sitting there.
So if you want to follow my friend Johnny who was just on the phone,
he's a very intelligent and fascinating dude.
It's Jonni,
Christo,
j,
o n n y,
c h R,
I s t o at Twitter.
And of course Brian Red van is red band,
and I'm Joe Rogan.
And you can subscribe to the death squad series of podcasts that Brian also
Helms that's on iTunes.
It's free to subscribe just like this one is,
and it's got Ari Shaffir as podcast,
Tom [inaudible] podcast,
Sam Tripoli's,
and uh,
maybe even Brian County in the future.
All right,
that's it.
Goodnight everybody.
Love you guys.
And I'll see you on Monday.
Bye Bye.
Later.